ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIBSON NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA. BARRICADE HAND BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH
BONTA BRO BURKE CALDERON
CARILLO CERVANTES CHAO GEN
DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY
DALY D. EGGMAN LARA FONG
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON. GLORIA
GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER KILEY JACKIE LEVINE
LIMON LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN SEG
THIS AREA OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK
RICK SILVA RAMOS REYES LOOSE
REBAJAS ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ
RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH.
STONE TEEN VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER
WICKS WORD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
OKAY MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
THE DAYS PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CREEK SILVA
IS QUICK SOMETHING. HEAVENLY
FATHER AS WE GATHER HERE TODAY
TO MAKE SERIOUS DECISIONS ON
BEHALF OF OUR CONSTITUENTS. I
ASK FOR GUIDANCE AND STRENGTH
FOR ALL OF US. I ASKED THAT WE
TAKE A PAUSE TO NOT LOOK AT
EACH OTHER AS REPUBLICANS OR
DEMOCRATS BUT AS PEOPLE WHO
CAME HERE TO SERVE THEIR
DISTRICTS. I ASK THAT WE BEGAN
TO HEAL AS INDIVIDUALS
COMMUNITIES AND AT THE STATE
AND NATION. AS A CHILD MY
PARENTS TAUGHT ME TO SAY MY
NIGHTLY PRAYERS AND I STILL DO
THIS LORD I ASK FOR YOUR HELP
WITH OUR WILDFIRES AND FOR THE
PROTECTION OF OUR FRONT LINE
WORKERS FROM FARMWORKERS
WORKING AN EXCESSIVE HEAT AND
SMOKE. TO OUR HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS WHO HAVE SEEN
FAMILIES DEVASTATED BY COVERT
NINETEEN. PLEASE PROTECT OUR
COOKS CASHIERS JANITORS AN
ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND OUR
BUSINESSES. LORD I ASK FOR
SPECIAL PRAYERS FOR VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN HIT
THE HARDEST I PRAY FOR THE
LATINO AND BLACK COMMUNITIES
THAT WE KNOW WE HAVE SUFFERED
WITH SO MUCH LOSS AND DEATH. I
ASK FOR YOUR WISDOM AND
GUIDANCE SO THAT WE CAN SHOW
EMPATHY AND LOVE AND KINDNESS
TO THOSE THAT NEED OUR HELP.
THE MOST. EVERY DAY WE SEE
HOMELESS ON OUR STREETS WE MUST
FIND SOLUTIONS INSTEAD OF
CASTING BLAME. I ASK THAT WE
LOOK AND NOT TURN AWAY FROM
THEM. LORD I ASK FOR YOUR
WATCHFUL EYE TO CARE FOR THOSE
THAT WE DO NOT SEE. AND THOSE
THAT SUFFER A LOAN FROM
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CHILD ABUSE
AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING. MY
NIGHTLY PRAYERS ALWAYS INCLUDE
MY OWN FAMILY THOSE AND THOSE
THAT I HAVE LOST AND I GO TO
BED ASKING FOR CHANGES THAT WE
NEED TO KEEP FAMILIES TOGETHER.
LORD SOMETIMES I GET ANGRY AND
MAD AND I QUESTION THINGS LIKE
HOW CAN WE RIP BABIES FROM
THEIR MOTHERS AND FATHERS ARMS
AND WHAT WILL WE DO WHEN
FAMILIES ARE EVICTED IN THE
FUTURE AND HOW WILL PEOPLE BE
FED AND CARED FOR. BUT I HAVE
TO BELIEVE THE LORD THAT YOU
HAVE THE ANSWERS AND WE HEAR
TODAY ON THIS ASSEMBLY FLOOR.
CAN MAKE CALIFORNIA A DRIVING
STATE ONCE AGAIN FINALLY LORD I
ASK YOU TO WRAP YOUR ARMS
AROUND OUR FIREFIGHTERS OR
POLICE OFFICERS OUR TEACHERS.
OUR MILITARY MEN AND WOMEN OUR
GOVERNOR AND OUR PRESIDENT GIVE
THEM THE STRAIGHT THROUGH THEIR
JOBS HONORABLY AND
COMPASSIONATELY. A MAN. THANK
YOU MISS CORK SILVA WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
CHOW. READY BEGIN I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA. AND
TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE. CHANCE FOR ALL.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY GERMAN
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY JUNE
ELEVENTH TWENTY TWENTY THE SIM
LIM NINETY ONLY AUDIBLE KEVIN
MULLIN SPEAKER PRO TEMPORE THE
ASSEMBLY RESIDING TO FOLKS WHO
PROGRAM THE DESK ASSISTANT FOR
DAVID BOWMAN READING THE ROLES
CALLED ASSEMBLYMEMBER WAKES ME
TO CONTROL THE ASSEMBLY MOTION
CARRY TIME OUT OF FIVE AM THE
SPEAKER PRO TEM DIRECT SERGEANT
AT ARMS TO CLOSE DOORS CARE
CALDERON MOVES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS THAT THE READING OF.
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATIONS
PETITION THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED. PARTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE. TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY. FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TYLER DEEP. FOR
FAMILY ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EGGMAN. FOR MEDICAL LEAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JIM FRAZIER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RANDY VOEPEL.
AMPHOTERIC THE LEAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BUFFY WICKS AND MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW SOME INTERESTING
TO. CHEN AS DAVID CHIU MEDINA
BLOOM O'DONNELL AND RODRIGUEZ
TO SPEAK ON AND A GERMAN MEMORY
TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER.
MEMBERS
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
SEVENTY SEVEN POINT. TWO I AM
REFERRING TO THE FOLLOWING
BILLS ITEM NUMBER SIX AB FOUR
SIXTY FIVE EGGMAN TO THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE. I AM ELEVEN
AB ELEVEN FORTY STONE AND ITEM
TWENTY AB TWENTY NINE SIXTY
SEVEN O'DONNELL. TO THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT
COMMITTEE. CAN ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN. AB FIFTEEN TWELVE
CARILLO TO THE LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE. AND
MISTER CALDERON YEAR AGAIN
RECOGNIZE AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR IS PLEASE MOVE THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TO THE INACTIVE
FILE ITEM EIGHT. I DON'T NUMBER
THIRTY ONE S. B. TWENTY NINE TO
RAZA AN ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY SIX
SB SIX SIXTY SEVEN HUESO. WORK
WILL NOT.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING. COOKERY. SENATE
BILL NINETY FIVE NINE TO NINETY
TWO FIVE TWO NINE INTO THE
BUILT IN TWENTY FOUR. ALL BILLS
HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS. DEEMED ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO. TAKE UP A SET OF AMENDMENTS
ON FILE ITEM. SIXTY FOUR. THIS
IS SB. TWELVE TWENTY. WITH
AMENDMENTS CLERK WILL READ WITH
AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL TWELVE
TWENTY WITHIN MINUTES BY SIMPLY
MEMBER BAUER K. HAND IS POWER
QUE HAN ON THE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES
BEFORE YOU DAYS SB TWELVE
TWENTY FOR PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS THESE AMENDMENTS
SIMPLY ADDRESS AFTER THE ISSUES
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MS BARRICADE
HAND SEE NO DISCLOSURE BAY AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE MEMBERS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. YOU GUYS HAVE
IT YOU MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED
BILLS OUT TO PRINT AND BACK ON
FILE. MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
THE TOP OF THE CONCURRENCE FILE.
THIS IS CONCURRENCE FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX PASS AND RETAIN.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER SEVEN. AB
FIVE EIGHTEEN CALDERON CARRILLO
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE EIGHTEEN BY
SOME REMEMBER CALDERON AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE IN THE STATE
GOVERNMENT MISTER CALDERON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
FIVE EIGHTEEN IS IT JUST A BILL
TO ALLOW THE CITY OF NORWALK TO
HAVE EXCLUSIVE RIGHTS INTO THE
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TO
PURCHASE THE VACANT SOUTHERN
YOUTH CORRECTIONAL RECEPTION
CENTER. AND CLINIC AT FAIR
MARKET VALUE IF IT IS DEEMED
SURPLUS THE PROPERTY BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE AND CONCURRENCY
SENTIMENTS. THANK YOU MISTER
CALDERON SENIOR DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ADAM. CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE ALL MEMBERS OF.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED AS OUT OF VOTE.
RIGHT NOW.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE VOTE HIGHS
FORTY TWO KNOWS ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS. R. CONCURRED IN
THIS IS FILE ITEM EIGHT AB
SEVEN THIRTY SIX. CORPORATE
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN THIRTY SIX
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN AN ACT
RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE UP
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. MS
ARE WHEN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER EIGHTY SEVEN THREE SIX
CLARIFIES AMBIGUITY AND CURRENT
LAW BY PROVIDING THAT PART TIME
ADJUNCT FACULTY AT NONPROFIT
INDEPENDENT COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES. CAN CONTINUE TO
BE TREATED AS THE EXEMPTS
PROFESSIONALS THEY ARE.
SPONSORED BY THE ASSOCIATION OF
INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA COLLEGES.
AND UNIVERSITIES AND SEIU
CALIFORNIA THIS BILL IS THE
PRODUCT OF MONTHS OF
COLLABORATION- REFLECTS
CONSENSUS BETWEEN BOTH THE
EMPLOYER AND THE EMPLOYEE
PARTICIPANTS. THE BILL HAS SET
BILL SETS A MINIMUM
COMPENSATION FLOOR BASED ON A
FORMULA FOR TOTAL HOURS OF
SERVICE NOT JUST CLASSROOM TOWN
TIME TO ACCOUNT FOR TIME
PREPARING FOR LESSONS GRADING
ASSIGNMENTS AND RESPONDING TO
STUDENTS- AND I MAY ADD THAT
WHEN THIS BILL ROUND LAST YEAR
IT HAD ZERO NO VOTES SO I
RESPECT. ASK FOR I. BOATS.
THANK YOU MISTER ONE. SEEING
NOTICE OR DEBATE ON THE ADAM.
CORPORAL MEMBERS DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS IDAHO. ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
YEAH. OKAY YEAH OKAY. THIS
TAKES FIFTY FOUR ON THE URGENCY
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLE. CHINA AS
FIFTY FIVE KNOWS YOUR ON THE
AIR I FIFTY FIVE NO ZERO ON THE
MAY SENATE AMENDMENTS WORKING
CURTAIN. THIS IS FILE ITEM NINE
A. B. NINE OH ONE CORPORATE
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE OH ONE BY
SIMPLY MEMBER GIPSON OTHERS AN
ACT RELATING TO JUVENILES
MISTER GIBSON. YOU'RE VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE OH ONE WHICH SEEKS-
SKINNER WHICH OF HIS BACK ON
CONCURRENT SENATE AMENDMENTS
REFLECTS- THE AGREEMENT MADE BY
ALL- WITH OPPOSITION INCLUDING
PROBATION THIS ATTORNEYS AND
EDUCATIONAL STAKEHOLDERS- WHO
HAVE GONE NEUTRAL ON THIS BILL
AT THIS POINT THERE ARE NO
FURTHER SUBSTANTIVE CONCERNS
FROM THE OPPOSITION THAT HAS
NOT BEEN ADDRESSED- THROUGH
THESE THE MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY. ASK WHEN I VOTE
ON NINE OH ONE. DAMES GIVE
SENSING THEIR DISCUSSION.
DEBATE ON THE ITEM CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS OF. WHAT
IS THAT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS TO GO. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRABLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF A
RESERVE A.
MISTER GIBSON MOVES
A CALL. WHAT A PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM TEN. ASCERTAIN A
FILE ITEM ELEVEN. PASS
TEMPORARILY AND FILE ITEM
TWELVE. THAT BRINGS US FILE
ITEM THIRTEEN AB TWELVE SEVENTY
SIX CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE SEVENTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA ON
ACTIVATING TO ELECTIONS MR
BONTA. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND COLLEAGUES A. B. TOLD
SEVENTY SIX IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE AB TEL SEVENTY SIX
IS A FOLLOW UP BILL TO AB EIGHT
FOUR NINE THE FAIR MAPS ACT.
WHICH WAS SIGNED BY GOVERNOR
NEWSOM LAST YEAR AND CREATED A
MORE FAIR LOCAL REDISTRICTING
PROCESS AB TWELVE SEVENTY SIX
MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES TO THE
FAIR MAPS ACT. ADDS BACK
NEGOTIATED LANGUAGE THAT WAS
INADVERTENTLY DELETED DURING
THE DRAFTING OF AB EIGHT FOUR
NINE AND CLARIFIES EXISTING LAW
IN CHARTER CITIES IT ALSO MAKES
NECESSARY ONE TIME ADJUSTMENTS
TO THE MAP ADOPTION PERIOD. IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO
ACCOMMODATE THE DELAYED CENSUS
TIMELINE I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR CONCURRENCE ON AB TWELVE
SEVENTY SIX. THANK YOU MR
BONTA. SEEING NO SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THE DESIRE
TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF THE. A
DESIRABLE. WELL CLOSER ROLE.
CALVET HIGHS FORTY TWO THOSE
NINE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. THIS IS FILE ITEM
FOURTEEN AB FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX BY SOME
REMEMBER BOERNER HORVATH
ANOTHER'S INOCULATING TO PUBLIC
RESOURCES MS BERNARD AT. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
FOURTEEN TWENTY SIX CODIFIES
THE SUBSTANCE OF TWO SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENTS THAT WERE SIGNED IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN BY CONSERVATION
ORGANIZATIONS. THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL THE öTHILL
TRANSPORTATION CORRIDOR AGENCY
CALTRANS THE NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY THEN THE NATIVE AMERICAN
HERITAGE COMMISSION AND THE
STATE PARK RECREATION
COMMISSION SETTLING MULTIPLE
LAWSUITS HAS SPENT NEARLY A
DECADE. TO PRESERVE AT TO
BRIDGE TO PREVENT ANY
INFRASTRUCTURE THREE SANOFI ST
BEACH THIS BILL ENJOYS SUPPORT
FROM VITAMIN A ORGANIZATIONS
BUILDING TRADES AND PARKS
SUPPORTERS THE BROAD COALITION
HAS FOUGHT TO SAVE TRESTLES.
AND SEND EVERY STATE BEACH PARK
FOR OVER A DECADE THE BILL HAS
NO OPPOSITION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A PRIVATE.
THANK YOU MS BERNARDA. SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ADAM
CORPORAL OF THE ROLE ALL
MEMBERS. IS THERE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS AT ABOUT. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES
FORTY SEVEN NO SIX SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT IN.
PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEM FIFTEEN
THIS BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN AB. EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE.
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN
FIFTY ONE BY SIMPLY MEMBER
WICKS AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE IN
THE LAND USE MISTER RIVAS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ON
BEHALF OF OUR COLLEGE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS. ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHTEEN FIFTY ONE IS HERE
FOR CONCURRENCE THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW FOR THE REUCTION OF
RESIDENTIAL PARKING
REQUIREMENTS ON RELIGIOUS
PROPERTIES. THIS BILL IS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
BOTH HOUSES SUPPORT FROM LOCAL.
ORGANIZATIONS OF FAITH NON
PROFITS. THE DEVELOPERS HOUSING
ADVOCATES SEE ORGANIZATIONS
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. THERE
WAS RIVAS SEEING NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE. CARCLUB THE ROLE. WHO
DESIRED ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS AND ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. DESIRABLE. THE PEOPLE
THAT WORK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT EYES FIFTY FOUR NO. ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN. THIS IS FILE ITEM SEVENTEEN
AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY ONE BY
MISTER KALRA COOKERY. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY TO THIRTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA NATURALLY
THE PUBLIC WORKS MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER HERE
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY
ONE BACK IN THE SENATE WHICH
DEFINES WHAT A PUBLIC SUBSIDIES
TO MINIMUS FOR THE PURPOSE OF
DETERMINING THE PREVAILING WAGE
APPLIES TO PRIVATE PROJECTS.
USING PUBLIC FUNDS UNDER
CURRENT LAW THE TERM TO
MINIMIZE IS NOT DEFINED IN
STATUTES THERE'S NO GUIDANCE AS
TO THE PROPER LEVEL PUBLIC
SUBSIDY THAT SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED DE MINIMUS. THIS IS
LEAD TO LITIGATION. THIS BILL
PROVIDES THAT A PUBLIC SUBSIDY
SUBSIDY ON A PRIVATE PROJECT IS
TO MINIMUS SO LONG AS IT IS
LESS THAN SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS. AND LESS THAN TWO
PERCENT. OF THE TOTAL PROJECT
COST. THIS BILL EXAMS THE
CONSTRUCTION OF SINGLE FAMILY
HOMES FROM THE SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLAR THRESHOLD. THE
MEMBERS TAKING THE SENATE IT
DID INCREASE THAT THRESHOLD FOR
PREVAILING WAGE FROM FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND TO SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND. UNDER CURRENT LAW AND
MAINTAIN UNDER THIS BILL NO
DEVELOPER IS REQUIRED TO TAKE A
PUBLIC SUBSIDY. OVER THE DE
MINIMIS AMOUNT THEY DO NOT WANT
TO PAY. THE PREVAILING WAGE
THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THERE WAS COVER.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. WHAT
IS THAT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THOSE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
CLARK
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES.
FORTY ONE KNOWS EIGHT SENATE
AMENDMENTS. CONCURRED. THIS IS
FOR ITEM EIGHTEEN. AB TWENTY
FOUR FIFTY NINE BY MR BIGELOW
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FOUR FIFTY NINE BY SIMPLY
BERMAN BIGELOW ANOTHER'S AN
ACCOLADE IN ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES
MISTER BIGELOW THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
NINE IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR SENIOR DISCUSSION
DEBATE. CLARK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. IT IS OUR VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRABLE. WELL
CLOSER ALL THE TIME ABOUT EYES
FIFTY NO ZERO SAN AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN THIS IS FILE
ITEM NINETEEN AB. TWENTY SIX
FORTY FOUR OR FOR REED SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY FORTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULD ANOTHER
SNACK LIKE A SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES DR WISE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I'M
PRESENTING AB TWENTY SIX FORTY
FOUR FOR CONCURRENCE AND SAID
AMENDMENTS THE BILL REQUIRES
DURING DECLARED EMERGENCIES
SUCH AS CURRENT CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC A SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY TO REPORT DISEASE
RELATED INFORMATION TO
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
INCLUDING EACH COMMUNICABLE
DISEASE RELATED DEATH OR
SUSPECTED DEATH WITHIN TWENTY
FOUR HOURS AND IN TURN REQUIRES
THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH TO MAKE THE TOTAL NUMBER
OF THESE TESTS AVAILABLE ON ITS
WEBSITE ON A WEEKLY BASIS THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS AUTHORIZE DPH
IS TO REQUIRE SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES TO REPORT ADDITIONAL
DISEASE RELATED DISEASE RELATED
INFORMATION INCLUDING A
REQUIRING SNIFFS TO NOTIFY
RESIDENTS AND THEIR
REPRESENTATIVES AND FAMILY
MEMBERS ABOUT CASES OF THE
DISEASE REQUIRES- SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES TO HAVE A
FULL TIME DEDICATED INFECTION
PREVENTION NEST. APPROXIMATELY
A THIRD OF THE KOBE DEATH IN
CALIFORNIA ATTRIBUTABLE TO
NURSING HOME RESIDENTS AND
STAFF WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
THESE FACILITIES ARE DOING
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO PREVENT
INFECTIONS THERE'S NO RESIDENTS
ARE SOME OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS DESERVE TO BE
PROTECTED. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THEY GET ACT
WOULD SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CARCLUB RURAL ALL MEMBERS.
DESERT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTED
IS THERE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT ABOUT. CLARK WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY
THREE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN
FILE ITEM. TWENTY ONE. AB
THIRTY TWO TWENTY EIGHT
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY TO TWENTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA ACCOLADE
TO DETENTION FACILITIES THIS
ABOUT. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AND COLLEAGUES SB THIRTY TWO
TWENTY EIGHT IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE IT PROVIDES
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVERSIGHT
FOR PROFIT PRIVATE PRISONS AND
IMMIGRATION DETENTION
FACILITIES IN OUR STATE IN
ORDER TO PROTECT THE HEALTH
SAFETY AND WELFARE. OF
CALIFORNIANS I MEMBERS TAKING
THE SENATE SIMPLIFY THE COR
PURPOSE OF THE BILL AND
ELIMINATE QUESTIONS ABOUT ANY
BURDEN AND COST PLACED ON STATE
OR LOCAL RESOURCES. LET'S DO
WHAT'S NECESSARY TO ENSURE
THESE FACILITIES THAT REMAIN
OPEN AND IN OPERATION AND HERE
TO THE APPROPRIATE STANDARDS OF
CARE PARTICULARLY AT SUCH A
CRITICAL MOMENT FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY AND HEALTH. ARE STRICTLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS BONTA SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE PARK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
YEAH CLARK WELL. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A CLERK WILL
CLOSE ROLE. TADARISE FORTY ONE
KNOWS NINE. SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE INCURRED IN.
MEMBERS ARE
PREPARED TO LET THE ALL ON
FILE ITEM NINE THIS IS MISTER
GIBSON'S AB NINE OH ONE
CORPORAL POST. ALL MEMBERS
HURDLE WHICH TO THEM ALL
MEMBERS VOTED WHICH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS FOR WHICH TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT AS FORTY TWO KNOWS EIGHT
SEVEN AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT.
BACK IN FILED ORDER. THIS IS
FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO AB THIRTY
TWO SEVENTY SEVEN CORPORATE
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY TWO
SEVENTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
JONES SAWYER ACCOLADE IN THE
PUBLIC PENALTIES MISTER JONES
SAWYER GOOD AFTERNOON MR
PRESIDENT. ACTUALLY MISTER
SPEAKER AB THIRTY TWO SEVENTY
SEVEN IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS REDUCE
THE DEBT CAP FOR INDIVIDUALS
ELIGIBILITY INDIVIDUALS FROM
SEVEN FIFTY TO FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS I WAS AMENDED TO
PROVIDE UP TO TWENTY FOUR
MONTHS TO ROLL IN A PAYMENT
PLAN AB THIRTY TWO SEVENTY
SEVEN BILL PROVIDES LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS WITH UP TO FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS IN PARKING GET.
THE ABILITY TO A ROLE IN
PAYMENT PLANS FOR INDIVIDUALS
FACING INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT
ECONOMIC STRAIN AS A RESULT OF
THE COBIT PANDEMIC THIS BILL
OFFERS IMPORTANT FINANCIAL
RELIEF THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
NO NO VOTES AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION. MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANKS JONES SAWYER
SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM CORPORAL OF THE
ROLE. YOU DESERVE IT ALL
MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
PARK WELL. CLOSER ALL THE TIME
BUT I FIFTY TWO NO ZERO SEVEN
AMENDMENTS. PARKING CURRENT.
THIS IS FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE.
AB. THIRTY THREE TWELVE. FIVE
MISTER GRAY CORPORATE ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY THREE TWELVE BY
SIMPLY MEMBER GRAY AN ACCOLADE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT MISTER
GREG THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB THIRTY THREE TWELVE
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS MAKE THIS
BILL BETTER I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
GRAY. SENIOR DISCUSSION BANCORP
LOVE ALL ALL MEMBERS OF. IS
THERE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I FIFTY
SIXNO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
OR CAN KERN. A RECONSIDERATION
ITEMS TWENTY FOUR THROUGH
TWENTY EIGHT ARE TO BE
CONTINUED. FOR THE PAST RETAIN
A FILE ITEMS TWENTY NINE AND
THIRTY ON ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING. WE ARE NOW AT SENATE
THIRD. WE'RE GOING TO PASS AND
RETAIN. ON FILE ITEM THIRTY ONE.
THROUGH. FORTY THREE. PASTORATE
HANNAH FILE ITEMS. FORTY FIVE.
THROUGH FORTY NINE.
PAST RETAIN
FILE ITEMS FIFTY ONE THROUGH
FIFTY FIVE ON A PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM. FIFTY
SIX PASSERINE TANNER FILE ITEMS.
FIFTY SEVEN THROUGH. SIXTY
THREE. WE DISPENSED WITH FILE
ITEM. SIXTY FOUR PASSER TANTA
FOUND SIXTY FIVE. WE'RE FILE
ITEMS SIXTY SIX THIS IS SB
FOURTEEN OH NINE. CORKERY
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN OH NINE BY
CENTER CABALLERO AN ACCOLADE
TAXATION. MAYES RUBIO THANK YOU
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE
TO PRESENT SB FOURTEEN OH NINE
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR KABBADI AT
ALL A BILL THAT WOULD REQUIRE
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD AS- TO
STUDY AN ISSUE PLAN TO INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF CLAIMS OF THE
CALIFORNIA- FEDERAL EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT. INCLUDING
ALTERNATIVE FILING SYSTEMS BUT
CAL E. I. T. C. IS ONE OF THE
MOST SUCCESSFUL ANTI POVERTY
PROGRAMS IN OUR STATE
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCING THE
NUMBER OF CHILDREN WHO LIVE IN
POVERTY. HOWEVER MANY OF
CALIFORNIA'S MOST ECONOMICALLY
FRAGILE HOUSEHOLDS DO NOT CLAIM
THE CREDIT FOR THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TAX YEAR F. T. B.
ESTIMATED ONE POINT TWO FIVE
MILLION ELIGIBLE TAX PAYERS
WOULD NOT CLAIM THE CAL E. I.
T. C. A RECENT STUDY. BY THE
CALIFORNIA POLICY LAB CONCLUDED
OUTRAGE ALONE IS NOT SUFFICIENT
TO INCREASE CLAIMS ABOUT CAL
EITC AMONG NOT NON FILERS. SB
FORTY NINE NINE WOULD GET US A
STEP CLOSER TO DELIVERING ON
THE PROMISE TO HELP THE
NEEDIEST FAMILIES TO MAKE ENDS
MEET. DUE TO THE COVERED
NINETEEN PANDEMIC FAMILIES NOW
FACE EXTREME FINANCIAL STRESS.
IN THESE TOUGH ECONOMIC TIMES
HARD WORKING FAMILIES NEED
ECONOMIC SUPPORT DELIVERED AS
EFFICIENTLY AND RAPIDLY AS
POSSIBLE. THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND HAS ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. NAME IS RUBIO SEEING
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. CLICK LIBERAL MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ADEBAYO. CLARK WELL
CLOSE ROLE. CALVET EYES FORTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. FOR THE PAST RETAIN A
FILE ITEM SIXTY SEVEN THIS IS
FILE ITEM SIXTY EIGHT SB
FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE. CORKERY
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE
BY SENATOR CABALLERO AN ACT
RELATING TO TRANSPORTATION.
MISTER GIBSON. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY SKEWS ME SAID
BILL FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR CAFIERO. SB
FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE IS A SIMPLE
BILL THAT WILL ALLOW THE CITY
OF SALINAS AND THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION TO
RELINQUISH PARTS OF THE STATE
ROUTE ONE EIGHTY THREE. EIGHT
ROUTE ONE EIGHTY THREE RUNS
THROUGH THE HEART OF THE
DOWNTOWN SILLINESS BY DOING
THIS THE CITY. WILL BE ABLE TO
REVITALIZE THEIR DOWNTOWN AND
SUPPORT THE CREATION OF NEW
BUSINESSES THIS BILL HAS
ENJOYED UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND HAS NO LOCALS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK NINE VOTE
FORCE ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
CAFIERO. ONE FORTY FIFTY NINE.
THINGS GIPSON. C. NOTICE
PRESSURE DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CORPORAL. RESERVE OUT ON
MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLE
TYLER NICE FORTY EIGHT NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS
FILE ITEMS SIXTY NINE THROUGH.
EIGHTY TWO. PASS RETAIN. THIS
IS FILE ITEM EIGHTY THREE SB
FIVE FIVE FIVE CORKERY. SENATE
BILL FIVE FIFTY FIVE BY SENATOR
MITCHELL ANOTHER SNACK LEAD TO
DETENTION FACILITIES MISTER
KALRA. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS SENATE BILL FIVE FIVE
FIVE BY SENATOR MITCHELL WILL
IMPROVE ACCESS TO COMMUNICATION
WITH LOVED ONES AND BASIC FOOD
AND HYGIENE PRODUCTS FOR PEOPLE
INCARCERATED IN COUNTY JAILS
AND JUVENILE FACILITIES ACROSS
THE STATE. IT WOULD DO SO BY
TOP CAP IN THE COST OF JAIL
CALLS ANDVIDEO COMMUNICATIONS
ENDING MARKUPS ON JAIL
COMMISSARY ITEMS AND REMOVING
MYRIAD FEES COMPANIES TALK ON
OF THESE GOODS. AND SERVICES.
THIS BILL ALSO ENSURE THAT
COUNTY INMATE WELFARE FUNDS ARE
USED SOLELY FOR THE BENEFIT AND
WELFARE OF INCARCERATED PEOPLE
BRING IN THE USE OF THESE FUNDS
BACK ONLINE WITH THEIR INTENDED
PURPOSE. AND ENDING THEIR USE
OF SUPPLEMENTAL SLUSH FUNDS ON
THE BACKS OF THOSE LEAST ABLE
TO PAY. DATA SHOWS THAT ONE OF
THE GREATEST INDICATORS OF THE
CARS ARE PER SUCCESSFUL RE
ENTRY IS THEIR ABILITY TO
REMAIN CONNECTED TO THEIR LOVED
ONES. AND COMMUNITY ON THE
OUTSIDE. MAKING THESE GOODS AND
SERVICES AFFORDABLE FOR
INCARCERATED PEOPLE KEEP SOME
CONNECT. HEALTHY AND READY TO
RETURN TO THEIR COMMUNITY. M.
IS A LONG NEEDED THIS RELIEF
BUT IT IS EVEN MORE URGENT IN
THE TIME OF COVERED.
INCARCERATED PEOPLE'S FAMILIES
ARE OVERLY BLACK LATINO AND
INDIGENOUS THESE ARE THE
COMMUNITIES SUFFERING THE MOST
FROM THE HEALTH AND ECONOMIC
IMPACTS OF THE PANDEMIC IN
CALIFORNIA. WE NEED THIS BILL
TO PROTECT THEIR LIMITED WEALTH
AND INCOME. THERE IS NO
VISITATION AND JAILS NOW CALLS
ARE NEEDED TO PROMOTE FAMILY
CONNECTION. FAMILY CONNECTION
MAKES US ALL SAFER OUR
COMMUNITY IS SAFER. REGARDING
CONCERT COMMISSARY PRODUCTS
PEOPLE IN JAILS ARE HUNGRY THE
PANDEMIC HAS INTERRUPTED SUPPLY
LINES AND INTERRUPTED NORMAL
VESSEL ACTIVITY PEOPLE RELY ON
THEIR ABILITY TO PURCHASE
COMMISSARY ITEMS TO KEEP
THEMSELVES HEALTHY. THE LIMITS
ON MARKING UP THESE ITEMS
INSTITUTE ABOUT SB FIVE FIFTY
FIVE WILL ALLOW PEOPLE TO MORE
EASILY PURCHASE FOOD AS WELL AS
BASICS A BASIC HYGIENE PRODUCTS
LIKE SOAP SHAMPOO AND
TOOTHPASTE. AS A FINAL NOTE I
OFFER THE REMINDER THE VAST
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE INCARCERATED
ARE COUNTY JAILS ARE THEIR PRE
TRIAL AND HAVE NEVER. BEEN
CONVICTED OF A CRIME. THE ARE
ALSO OTHER TO EARN INCOME
DURING TIME MAKING ENTIRE
DEPENDENT ON THEIR FAMILIES TO
PAY FOR NOT ONLY THE GOODS AND
SERVICES. POWER BY THIS BILL
BUT RENT CHILD CARE AND OTHER
FINANCIAL OBLIGATIONS THE
FAMILY MAY HAVE. YOU SHOULD NOT
BE MAKING IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR
PEOPLE TO CARE FOR THEMSELVES
DURING AN ALREADY STRESSFUL
PERIOD IN THEIR LIVES. BY
ALLOWING THEM TO BE PROBABLY
PRICE GOUGE AND SUBJECT TO
PREDATORY INDUSTRY PRACTICES.
THIS BILL IS SMART AND HUMANE
FOR MOST ECONOMIC WELL BEING
FOR LOW INCOME FAMILIES.
FEDERAL APPROVED PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND AS IT IS QUITE LIKELY- IT
IS THE LAST BILL THAT WE WILL
BE HEARING FROM SENATOR
MITCHELL. I WANT TO THANK HER
FOR ALLOWING ME THE HONOR TO
PRESENT T. AND IT'S ALIGNED
WITH HUMANITY THAT SHE'S ALWAYS
SHOWN AS A LEGISLATOR IN THIS
BUILDING WITH ADDRESS MUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER KALRA
SEE NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. ON
THE ITEM CARPAL OF THE ROLE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
MISTER
CALDERON MOVES A CALL. FOR THE
PAST RETAIN FILE ITEM EIGHTY
FOUR. THIS IS FILE ITEM EIGHTY
FIVE SB FIVE NINETY SIX
CORPORATION SENATE BILL FIVE
NINETY SIX BY SENATOR STERN
ACCOLADE IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES. DOCTOR REGULAR.
MISTER SPEAKER THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT ON SENATE BILL
FIVE NINETY SIX ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR STERN. LAST FALL PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFFS LEFT
MORE THAN TWO MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT POWER
SOMETIMES DAYS ON END. THESE
POS PF EVENTS AFFECTED
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE ALL OVER
THE STATE WHO ARE MEDICALLY
VULNERABLE LOVED ONES AND
NEIGHBORS WHOSE LIVES DEPENDED
ON THE POWER WHETHER IT'S USED
TO RUN A RESPIRATOR OR TO
REFRIGERATE MEDICATIONS. THAT'S
WHY UTILITIES PROVIDE A MEDICAL
BASELINE PROGRAM THAT LOWERS
ENERGY BILLS AND GIVES ADVANCE
NOTICE OF POSSIBLE POWER SHUT
OFFS HELPING CUSTOMERS MEET
THEIR ENERGY AND MEDICAL NEEDS
WITHIN THEIR MEANS WITHIN THEIR
MIDDLE AND WORKING CLASS
BUDGETS. SB FIVE NINETY SIX
EXPAND OUTREACH AND AWARENESS
OF THIS PROGRAM BY PROVIDING
AUTHORITY FOR COUNTY WELFARE
DEPARTMENT TO INFORM I. HSS
APPLICANTS AND RECIPIENTS ABOUT
THIS PROGRAM. THOSE COUNTIES
MOST AFFECTED BY PS PS ARE MOST
LIKELY TO SHARE THIS IMPORTANT
INFORMATION WITH THOSE
RECEIVING IHS US SERVICES THIS
BILL IS SUPPORTED BY DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA BY THE UNITED
DOMESTIC WORKERS AND THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA. THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
DOCTOR REGULAR. SEEING THEIR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CORPORAL. YOU DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS A DESIRE TO
VOTE. ONE MORE. BURKE WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY
EIGHT NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES PASS RETAIN A FILE ITEMS
EIGHTY SIX. THROUGH. EIGHTY
NINE. WE'RE GOING TO PASS AND
RETAIN A FILE ITEM NINETY ONE.
BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM NINETY
TWO. SB EIGHT FIFTY FIVE
QUICKLY. SENATE BILL A FIFTY
FIVE BY CENTER WIENER ANOTHER'S
ACCOLADE HEALTH COVERAGE DOCTOR
REGULARLY MAKE AN OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBER I
RISE TODAY AS A PROUD CO AUTHOR
TO PRESENT ON SENATE BILL EIGHT
FIVE FIFTY FIVE ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR WIENER. SENATE BILL
EIGHT FIFTY FIVE REQUIRES
HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS TO COVER
MEDICALLY NECESSARY TREATMENT
FOR ALL MEDICAL AND MENTAL OR
EXCUSE ME ALL MENTAL ILLNESS
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS.
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA MENTAL
HEALTH PARITY ACT. SENATE BILL
EIGHT FIFTY FIVE ALSO CLARIFIES
THAT HEALTH PLANS MUST ARRANGE
TIMELY ACCESS TO OUT OF NETWORK
CARE IN CASES WHERE AN N
NETWORK PROVIDER CANNOT BE
SECURED WITHIN THE EXISTING
GEOGRAPHIC AND TIMELY ACCESS
STANDARDS. IN NINETEEN NINETY
NINE THE CALIFORNIA MENTAL
HEALTH PARITY ACT WAS ENACTED
TO REQUIRE COVERAGE OF
MEDICALLY NECESSARY TREATMENT
FOR NINE SEVERE MENTAL
ILLNESSES. THE MAJORITY OF
MENTAL ILLNESSES AND ALL
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS ARE NOT
SUBJECT TO ITS PROTECTIONS SOME
OF THESE EXCLUDED CONDITIONS
INCLUDE. PTSD GENERALIZED
ANXIETY DISORDER. OPIOID USE
DISORDER ALCOHOL USE DISORDER
BINGE EATING DISORDER AND MAJOR
NEUROCOGNITIVE DISORDER DUE TO
TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY. SENATE
BILL EIGHT FIFTY FIVE IS
CRITICAL LEGISLATION FOR
ENSURING CALIFORNIANS LIVING
WITH MENTAL HEALTH OR SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDERS ARE TREATED WITH
DIGNITY AND RESPECT WHEN
ACCESSING NEEDED HEALTH CARE
AND THAT INDIVIDUALS RECEIVE
ALL MEDICALLY NECESSARY
TREATMENT BEFORE THEY ARE IN
CRISIS. WHEN PEOPLE CAN'T GET
THE TREATMENT THAT THEY NEED
THE COSTA SHIFTED ON TO MEDICAL
AND TAXPAYERS IN THE FORM OF
HOMELESSNESS DISABILITY AND
UNNECESSARY INCARCERATION. THIS
BILL GETS AT THE OOT OF MANY
OF THESE SOCIAL ISSUES AND
ATTEMPTS TO ADDRESS IT BEFORE
IT TAKES THE FORM OF SOMETHING
MUCH GREATER. IT IS TIME THAT
WE STOP FORCING PEOPLE THAT THE
TO DESCEND INTO A CRISIS BEFORE
THEIR HEALTH COVERAGE KICKS IN.
THIS IS BEEN THE STATUS QUO FOR
FAR TOO LONG. THE UC ANALYSIS
FOUND THAT COVERING ALL MENTAL
HEALTH. MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS WHAT
INCREASE IN INSURANCE
EXPENDITURES BY ONLY TWO POINT
ZERO ZERO TWO PERCENT. THIS
NEGLIGIBLE INCREASE IS
ESSENTIALLY A ROUNDING ERROR
BUT IT WILL COVER THE COST OF
INSURING CALIFORNIANS SUFFERING
WITH MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS HAVE
ACCESS TO NEEDED BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES. COLLEAGUES
CALIFORNIA IS EXPERIENCING A
MENTAL HEALTH AND ADDICTION
CRISIS THAT IS ONLY WORSENING
AS PEOPLE CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE
WITH THE LASTING EFFECTS OF
COVERT NINETEEN. THE NEGATIVE
PSYCHOLOGICAL AND SOCIAL
DIMENSIONS OF THIS PANDEMIC
CAUSED BY THE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING THE SOCIAL ISOLATION
THE JOBLESSNESS THE FINANCIAL
STRESS AND ANXIETY WILL BE FELT
BY CALIFORNIANS. FOR YEARS TO
COME. SENATE BILL EIGHT FIFTY
FIVE IS CRITICAL TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIANS RESPONSE TO THIS
PANDEMIC IS SWIFT AND
APPROPRIATE. SENATE BILL EIGHT
FIFTY FIVE WILL SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASE ACCESS TO MEDICALLY
NECESSARY HEALTH CARE GIVING
PEOPLE LIVING WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS THE ABILITY TO ACCESS
TREATMENT SOONER. TO GET BACK
ON THEIR FEET AND TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE SUPPORT THAT
THEY NEED. THANK A DOCTORATE
LEVEL MISS WALDRON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MR SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS. ARE RISE ALSO AS A
PROUD CO AUTHOR OF SB EIGHT
FIVE FIVE WHICH WOULD FINALLY
CREATE TO PARITY BETWEEN
COVERAGE OF PHYSICAL AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. COVERT
NINETEEN HAS NOT ONLY
COMPOUNDED CALIFORNIA'S
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CRISIS. BUT
ALSO EXPOSE SEVERE GAPS IN OUR
TREATMENT SYSTEM FOR EXAMPLE
ACCORDING TO THE KENNEDY FORUM
90% OF PEOPLE NEEDING SUBSTANCE
USE TREATMENT DID NOT RECEIVE
IT. WHILE 60% OF ADULTS WITH
MENTAL HEALTH DISORDERS DID NOT
RECEIVE TREATMENT IN THE PAST
YEAR. THE STANFORD INITIATIVE
ON ADDICTION OF WHICH I AM A
MEMBER. HAS STUDIES OF THE
BRAIN SHOWING THAT THERE IS A
DIRECT PHYSICAL CONNECTION
BETWEEN ADDICTION. AND THE
BRAIN. WHY DO WE CONTINUE TO
NOT ADDRESS THE PARITY ISSUE
BETWEEN PHYSICAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH. SB EIGHT FIVE FIVE
MODERNIZES CALIFORNIA'S ARCHAIC
PARITY LAW ENSURING COVERAGE OF
MEDICALLY NECESSARY TREATMENT.
FOR ALL MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS THIS
BILL RECOGNIZES THE STRONG LINK
BETWEEN PHYSICAL AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH ISSUES. AND IT WILL
UNDOUBTEDLY INCREASE ACCESS TO
QUALITY CARE WHILE ALSO DRIVING
DOWN COSTS AYE ORIGIN AYE VOTE.
THERE WAS WATER MISTER COOLEY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED COLLEAGUES
I'M PLEASED TO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THIS BILL IS A
GOOD UPDATE TO THE LOSS OF
COVERAGE. WHEN YOU GET IN THE
FIELD OF INSURANCE GENERALLY
HEALTH INSURANCE ALL THE
COVERAGES. THE CONTRACTS THE
WAY THEY'RE STRUCTURE DISORDER
PAST MODELS OF DELIVERY HOW
THINGS WERE DONE IN THE PAST
THEY MAKE CONNECTIONS BUT- AS
TIME GOES ON IT BECOMES EVIDENT
THAT THEY'RE JUST AREAS IN
WHICH THE SUPERSTRUCTURE YOU
ARE DRAGGING AROUND IN YOUR
FIELDS FOR ABOUT ODDS WITH
DELIVERY. NEEDED CARE THIS BILL
IS TIMELY IT UPDATES- AN
IMPORTANT FIELD LAW AND FRANKLY
WORK IN THE IN THE AREAS WERE.
DOING THE UPDATE YOU'RE DEALING
WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE VULNERABLE
AND ESPECIALLY AT RISK AND- AT
RISK OF BEING OVERLOOKED SO
VERY VERY TIMELY BILL ORIGINAL
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS COOLEY
SAYING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION DR REMO- YOU MAY
CLOSE IF YOU WISH. POLICE ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. OUR CLUB THE
ROLE. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT ICE FORTY TWO KNOWS ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES. PASTORATE
ON. FIVE NINETY THREE NINETY
FOUR. THIS IS FILE ITEM NINETY
FIVE S. B. NINE TWELVE BY
MISTER GIBSON. PRESENTING BY
MISTER GIBSON QUICKLY SENATE
BILL NINE TWELVE BY SENATOR
BILL ANOTHER'S MEDICALLY FOSTER
CARE TO CLEARING THE URGENCY
THERE UP TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. MISTER GIBSON
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT SB NINE TWELVE WHICH
SEEKS STABILITY- INSURERS ARE
FOSTER YOUTH IN CALIFORNIA AS A
MEMBER I HAVE WORKS TO BETTER
TO BETTER THE CONDITIONS OF
OFFER YOU- SINCE I'VE BEEN IN%
THIS BUILDING. I WANT TO BEGIN
TO THANK THE LEADERSHIP OF BOTH
HOUSES AND ADMINISTRATION FOR
CONTINUED TO FOR COMING TO AN
AGREEMENT WHICH PROTECTS FOSTER
YOU FOR A YEAR ALLOWING THEM
TIME TO RECOVER FROM THE COLD
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. THIS EXTENDS
THIS EXTENSION OF SERVICES
COULD NOT HAVE BEEN MORE TIMELY
FOR THOUSANDS OF FOSTER YOU
THROUGHOUT THIS STATE. WHILE
THIS WAS AN STEP THERE'S STILL
WORK TO BE DONE. SB NINE TWELVE
USE THIS MOMENT AS AN EXAMPLE
TO AND APPLY THE ACTIONS TAKEN
THIS YEAR TO FUTURE EMERGENCY
PANDEMIC AND DISASTERS WELL WE
HOPE. WE NEVER SEE THIS AGAIN
THERE IS REASONABLE EVIDENCE
THAT THIS MAY NOT BE THE LAST
EMERGENCY OF THIS PANDEMIC OR
STATE WIDE EMERGENCIES WHILE WE
DEBATE AND NEGOTIATE AT THIS
BUDGET FOSTER YOUTH WHO HAVE
ALREADY BEEN ABUSED NEGLECTED
GREW UP IN EXCITING AND
DEPRESSION OVER THE
UNCERTAINTIES OF IN THEIR
FUTURE. S. B. NINE TWELVE MOVES
FORWARD WILL CREATE AN
EMERGENCY PROTOCOL TO PROTECT
FOSTER YOU THIS BILL WILL
ENSURE THAT UPON THE STATEWIDE
DECLARATION FOR EMERGENCIES
FOSTER YOUTH WILL HAVE THE
STABILITY AND PLACEMENT FOR THE
NEXT SIX MONTHS THIS BILL WILL
ALSO INCLUDE LANGUAGE. WHICH
BUILDS UPON THE BUDGET DEAL AND
INCLUDE ALL FOSTER YOUTH WHO
WERE AFFECTED BY THE SHELTER IN
PLACE ORDER STATE EMERGENCIES
DO NOT WORK ACCORDING TO THE
LEGISLATIVE CALENDAR DOES IT IS
VITAL THAT WE HAVE PROVISIONS
IN PLACE FOR THOSE WHO NEED IT
THE MOST ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
BELL I RESPECTFULLY ASK BUT I
VOTE. ON SENATE BILL NINE
TWELVE. THINGS GIPSON MR COOLEY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. COLLEAGUES
ARE ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS ON BEHALF OF FOSTER YOUTH.
YOU KNOW THEY'RE EASILY
OVERLOOKED THIS BILL GIVES A
WORKAROUND IN FUTURE TIMES IF
THERE'S EVER ANY SETBACK. THAT
COMPLICATES THE DELIVERY OF
SERVICES YOU TO GIVE THAT A
PATH. IT'S A VERY GOOD BILL
PROVIDES FLEXIBILITY TO MEET.
NEEDS IRISH AND I WILL. THANKS
COOLEY SAY NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. CLARK LIBERAL MEMBERS.
THESE ARE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. THIS TAKES
FIFTY FOUR ON THE URGENCY THE
NEW YORK.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES FIFTY FOUR
NO ZERO ON THE URGENCY AS FIFTY
FOUR NO ZERO ON THE MEASURE.
THAT BILL PASSES THIS IS FILE
ITEM NINETY SIX SB NINE SEVEN
THREE CORPORATE SENATE BILL
NINE SEVENTY THREE BY SENATOR
JACKSON ANOTHER REASON ACCOLADE
TO EMPLOYMENT MS GARCIA. THANK
YOU MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ARE
HAPPY I WOMEN'S EQUALITY DAY
TODAY A HUNDRED YEARS AGO WE
GOT THE RIGHT TO VOTE AND WE'RE
STILL FAR FROM PARITY ALTHOUGH
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF PROGRESS
AND SO IT'S ONLY FITTING THAT
WE GET TO HEAR SB NINE SEVENTY
THREE TODAY WHICH I'M A- PROUD
CO AUTHOR OF. I THIS BILL
PRICES PAY DISCRIMINATION WITH
DATA I WITH INFORMATION BECAUSE
WHEN IT COMES TO PAY EQUITY FOR
WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF COLOR. I
BELIEVE WE CAN'T FIX IT WE
DON'T KNOW. HERE'S WHAT WE DO
KNOW. THE PAY GAP REMAINS A
SERIOUS PROBLEM THAT COST AN
ESTIMATED SEVENTY NINE BILLION
AND LOST WAGES. A YEAR FOR
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES. APA WOMEN
MAKE EIGHTY FIVE CENTS FOR
EVERY DOLLAR THAT WHITE MALE
COUNTERPART MAKES. BLACK WOMEN
MAKE SIXTY TWO CENTS FOR EVERY
DOLLAR THEIR WHITE MALE
COUNTERPART MAKES. AT THE VERY
BOTTOM OF THE NINTH THE BILL
GETTING EARNED ABOUT FIFTY FOUR
CENTS FOR EVERY DOLLAR EARNED
BY THE WHITE MAN. TO GET A
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE LET'S
ENOUGH WITH WORK. TWENTY THREE
MONTHS IN ORDER TURN WHITE MEN
AREN'T IN TWELVE MONTHS. IN
ADDITION TO THE WAGE GAP
BETWEEN WHITE AND BLACK. MAN
IS. PUT BLACK MAN IS TWENTY SIX
POINT 5% A NUMBER THAT HAS
INCREASED SINCE THE YEAR TWO
THOUSAND A DECREASE. ON TOP OF
ALL THESE MEN AND WOMEN OF
COLOR HAVE WILL HAVE TO ALSO
DEAL WITH DISCRIMINATION IN THE
WORKPLACE. BEFORE THE SPEND
THEM BACK RECENT STUDIES
PREDICTED THAT WE WOULD NOT
FULLY CLOSE THE PAY GAP FOR A
HUNDRED AND ONE HERE'S- WE KNOW
THAT BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC.
WOMEN PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE BEING
ADVERSELY IMPACTED BY COVERT
NINETEEN AND WE'RE PROBABLY
FURTHER AWAY FROM THAT CRISIS.
COLLECTING INFORMATION IS GOING
TO HELP US TO BE ABLE TO BETTER
FIGHT THIS INEQUITY. AND IN
CASE YOU'RE WONDERING AT THE
DATA MAKES A DIFFERENCE LET ME
GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE. LAST YEAR
THE COMPANY INTEL VOLUNTARILY
RELEASES DATA AND REVEAL THAT.
FORTY ONE OF FIFTY TWO TOP
EXECUTIVES MAKING MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
WERE MEN. THIRTY SEVEN OR WHITE
MEN THIS REVELATION WAS I
OPENING THAT HAS LET HER CALL
FOR CHANGE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. DAVIS GARCIA
SEEING IT NO- DISCUSSION DEBATE
ON THE OUT OF WORK OF THE ROLE.
ZERO ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS A DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF
A.
MISTER SEA A MOVES A CALL.
WHAT A PASS TEMPORARILY. FILE
ITEM NINETY SEVEN PASS RETAIN
ON FILE ITEM. NINETY EIGHT.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NINETY NINE
SB. TEN SIXTY FIVE. KERKORIAN
SENATE BILL TEN SIXTY FIVE BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE OF PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES MR MAIENSCHEIN THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR THE GLOBAL
PANDEMIC SPAWNED BY THE CORONA
VIRUS OUTBREAK IS MORE THAN A
MEDICAL EMERGENCY IT'S ALSO AN
ECONOMIC DISASTER IN THE
MAKING. THE IMPACT OF
HOMELESSNESS ON CHILDREN IS
ESPECIALLY DEVASTATING WITH
ISSUE SPANNING FROM HUNGER
LOWERED ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT
INCREASES IN STRESS AND
DEPRESSION DEVELOPMENTAL DELAYS
AND OVERALL POOR MENTAL HEALTH
SB TEN SIXTY FIVE ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR HERTZBERG REINFORCES
CALIFORNIA'S COMMITMENT TO
SAFETY TO SAFEWAY HOUSING
CHILDREN THEIR FAMILIES BY
MAKING MEANINGFUL IMPROVEMENTS
TO THE COW WORKS HOMELESSNESS.
PROGRAM NO FAMILY SHOULD BE
WITHOUT SHELTER ESPECIALLY THIS
TIME A PANDEMIC AND ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTY I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
WITH MAIENSCHEIN. C. NOTICE
KASHER DEBATE ON THE ITEM. OUR
CLUB IN THE ROLE. THESE ARE
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VETERANS ARE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
CEREMONY.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLE
CHINA AND I FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES. THE DALLAS.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK IN THE FILE THE FILE ITEM
NINETY SEVEN IS FILE ITEM
NINETY SEVEN. SB TEN FORTY
FOUR. CORKERY SENATE BILL TEN
FORTY FOUR BY SENATOR ALLEN
ANOTHER SNACK LATER FIRE
PROTECTION. MISS BARAKAT THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TO
PRESENT SB TEN FORTY FOUR ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR ALAN TEN
FORTY FOUR PROHIBITS THE
MANUFACTURE SALE AND USE OF
CERTAIN FIREFIGHTING FOAM THAT
CONTAINS THE CHEMICALS PER AND
POLYFLUOROALKYL SUBSTANCES
WHICH ARE KNOWN AS P. FIVE. P.
FATHER CHEMICALS THE BUILD UP
IN OUR BODIES IN ARLINGTON
NUMEROUS HEALTH PROBLEMS
INCLUDING CANCER AND DAMAGE TO
THE KIDNEYS AND LIVER. HE
FOSTER ESPECIALLY HARMFUL TO
INFANTS AND CHILDREN CAN CAUSE
DAMAGE THE LAST INTO ADULTHOOD
THESE DANGEROUS CHEMICALS
CONTAMINATE DRINKING WATER
AROUND THE COUNTRY WITH A
PROJECTED COSTS ARE WATER
UTILITIES OF TWELVE POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS OVER THE NEXT
DECADE. IN CALIFORNIA THE WATER
SUPPLIES RELEASE SEVEN POINT
FIVE MILLION PEOPLE NOW HAVE P.
FUSS A PRIMARY SOURCE OF
CONTAMINATION PARTICULARLY FOR
OUR WATER SUPPLY ARE THESE
FIREFIGHTING FOAMS USED TO
FIGHT WITH WOOD FIRES.
FIREFIGHTERS ARE ALREADY IN AN
INCREASED RISK OF DEVELOPING
HEALTH PROBLEMS ELEVATED LEVELS
OF PFOS CHEMICALS HAVE BEEN
DOCUMENTED IN THE BODIES OF
FIREFIGHTERS. PUTTING THEM AT
EVEN GREATER RISK OF HARM
INCLUDING CANCER. THANKFULLY
THE USE OF P. FOSSEN
FIREFIGHTING FOAM IS NOT
NECESSARY. CURRENTLY AVAILABLE
ALTERNATIVES ARE EFFECTIVE COST
SAVING AND ARE IN USE GLOBALLY
pAIRPORT AND ALL MAJOR
AUSTRALIAN AIRPORTS. OF THE U.
S. STATES HAVE ALREADY ENACTED
LAWS THAT BAN MOST PEOPLE AS
CONTAINING FIREFIGHTING FOAM.
SB TEN FORTY FOUR TAKES A LONG
OVERDUE STEP OF BANNING THE USE
OF THIS PHONE CONTAINING P.
FOSS. IN MY OWN DISTRICT WE'VE
SEEN WATER WELLS SHUT DOWN AS A
RESULT OF THE CONTAMINATION AND
THAT IS BEEN CAUSED BY THESE
PHONES. THE AUTHOR REACHING
AGREEMENT WITH THE OPPOSITION
COALITION THE BILL HAS BEEN
AMENDED TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
TIME AND FLEXIBILITY FOR THE
INDUSTRY TO TRANSITION AWAY
FROM THESE P. FAST PHONES. AND
PROVIDES IMPORTANT IMPORTANT
CONTAINMENT PROVISIONS FOR ANY
USES BEYOND TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TO PREVENT THE RELEASE OF THESE
PHONES INTO THE ENVIRONMENT.
MEMBER THESE MEMBERS THIS IS A
COMMON SENSE MEASURE THE WATER
AGENCIES ARE SUPPORTING THE
BILL SO THAT WE WILL GET THOSE
CONTAMINANTS NATION LEVELS DOWN
IN OUR DRINKING WATER. THE
LEAST WE CAN DO IS STOP MAKING
THESE PROBLEMS IN OUR WATER
WORSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU MS
BACKING HIM. SEEING THEIR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CARCLUB
THEY'RE ALL. MEMBERS DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL CLOSE ROLE
TIVER EYES FIFTY TWO KNOWS
ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO GO BACK
IN THE FILE THE FILE ITEM FIFTY
SIXTHIS IS SENATE BILL. NINE
SEVEN TWO. CORKERY. SENATE BILL
NINE SEVENTY TWO BY SERVICE
CORRECTLY THE TAXATION. MR
GABRIEL. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I'M PLEASED TODAY TO
PRESENT THE SENATE BILL NINE
SEVEN TO THE CORPORATE
DISCLOSURE ACT ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR SKINNER. SB NINE SEVEN
TWO WILL BETTER INFORM
CALIFORNIA'S POLICY DECISIONS
BY REQUIRING LARGE CORPORATIONS
TO DISCLOSE INFORMATION ABOUT
THEIR TAX BURDEN. AND THE
UTILIZATION OF STATE TAX
CREDITS. EACH YEAR CALIFORNIA
PROVIDES BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
TAX BENEFITS TO CORPORATIONS.
WHAT TAX CREDITS ARE AN
IMPORTANT TOOL THAT CAN HELP TO
ADVANCE MANY LAUDABLE POLICY
OBJECTIVES. CURRENT LAW
ACTUALLY PREVENTS POLICYMAKERS
AND THE PUBLIC FROM ACCESSING
BASIC INFORMATION. SUCH AS THE
SPECIFIC TAX CREDITS CLAIMED BY
CORPORATION OR THE AMOUNT OF
TAXES PAID TO THE STATE. SB
NINE SEVEN TWO. IS A MODEST AND
PRACTICAL MEASURE THAT WILL
LINE CALIFORNIA WITH NUMEROUS
OTHER STATES THAT REQUIRE SUCH
DISCLOSURE. AS WELL AS WITH
FEDERAL POLICY THAT REQUIRES
PUBLICLY TRADED CORPORATIONS TO
PROVIDE TAX INFORMATION TO THE
SEC. TO BE CLEAR SB NINE SEVEN
TWO DOES NOT INCREASE TAXES NOR
DOES IT MAKE ANY CHANGES TO
EXISTING TAX CREDIT. THE BILL
SIMPLY REQUIRES THE DISCLOSURE
OF THREE BASIC DATA POINTS FOR
CORPORATIONS WITH GROSS
RECEIPTS OVER FIVE BILLION. THE
TOTAL DOLLAR VALUE OF STATE TAX
KIND OF TAX BENEFITS CLAIMS THE
TYPES OF TAX CREDITS USED AND
THE AMOUNT OF TAX PAID DIRECTLY
TO THE STATE. THE INFORMATION
WILL BE PROVIDED BY THE F. T.
B. TO THE LEGISLATURE TO HELP
INFORM OUR POLICY MAKING
DECISIONS ESPECIALLY AS THEY
RELATE TO TAXES AND OUR BUDGET
PROCESS. SB NINE SEVEN TWO IS
NOT DESIGNED TO PUBLICLY SHAME
LARGE CORPORATIONS RATHER IT
MERELY PROVIDES POLICYMAKERS
AND THE PUBLIC WITH BASIC
INFORMATION THAT IS ESSENTIAL
TO CRAFTING SMART. DATA DRIVEN
PUBLIC POLICY. SB NINE SEVEN
TWO IS SPONSORED BY SEIU AND A
COALITION OF LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS AND IS AN
IMPORTANT MODEST AND PRACTICAL
STEP TO INCREASE PUBLIC
TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY. THANK YOU AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR GABRIEL
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE- ALL MEMBERS
VOTED EITHER TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THIRTY VOTE.
ALL ARMORS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS THIRTY THIRD READ
THIS FIRST FORTY ONE.
MR
GABRIEL MOVE THE CALL. WE ARE
GOING TO LIFT THE CALL ON SB
NINE SEVENTY THREE FILE ITEM
NINETY SIX THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED VERY VOTE.
HOME MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE. TOM MEMBERS THIRTY
THIRTY VOTE. WILL LOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THOSE EYES FORTY
TWO NEWS EIGHT THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE UP IN FILE ITEM ORDER TO
FILE ITEM TEN THE SPEAKER PRO
TEM IS FILE ITEM AB NINE NINETY
TO THE CLERK WILL READ. SOME
AGO NINE NINETY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MULLIN ACRYLATE
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT STERLING
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS AB NINE
AND TWO SIMPLY CLARIFIES TO
MEMBERS OF LOCAL ELECTED BODIES
MAY ENGAGE ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
PROVIDED THEY DO NOT
INTERACTION ANYWAY THE VIOLATES
VIOLATES THE RALPH M. BROWN ACT
MORE SPECIFICALLY A. B. NINE
AND TWO ALLOWS MEMBERS TO USE
SOCIAL MEDIA PROVIDED THAT A
MAJORITY OF THE MEMBERS DO NOT
DISCUSS AMONG THEMSELVES
BUSINESS OF A SPECIFIC NATURE.
THAT IS WITHIN THE SUBJECT
MATTER JURISDICTION OF THE
LEGISLATIVE BODY OF THE LOCAL
AGENCY RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE ON CONCURRENCE. THANK
YOU MISTER MULLIN SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. MEMBERS VOTED THIRD
OF THE- ALL MEMBERS VOTED TWO
THIRDS VOTE. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE HIGHS FORTY NINE NO ZERO
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS MOVING BACK TO FILE
ORDER. FILE ITEM ONE OH EIGHT.
SB TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN THE CLERK
WILL READ SENATE BILL TWELVE
FIFTY SEVEN BY SENATOR ROSALYN
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO
EMPLOYMENT. THE THREE OF US YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS HOUSEHOLD WORKERS
NANNIES HOUSEKEEPERS AND HOME
CARE WORKERS AND DAY LABORERS
LIKE GARDENERS ARE THE ONLY
GROUP OF WORKERS WHO ARE
EXCLUDED FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DIVISION OF OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY
AND HEALTH CAL OSHA
PROTECTIONS. THE COVERT
NINETEEN HEALTH PANDEMIC AND
THE CURRENT. OF CATASTROPHIC
CALIFORNIA WILDFIRES HAVE MADE
IT CLEAR THAT DOMESTIC WORKERS
HEALTH AND THEIR VERY LIVES ARE
IN DANGER BECAUSE THEY ARE
EXCLUDED FROM CAL OSHA. THE
PANDEMIC HAS EXPOSED THE GRAVE
HEALTH INEQUITIES OF OUR STATE
WITH BLACK AND LATINO
CALIFORNIANS.
DISPROPORTIONATELY BEARING THE
HEALTH AND ECONOMIC IMPACTS OF
THE CRISIS AS LOW WAGE AN
ESSENTIAL WORKERS. THIS IS WHY
THE CALIFORNIA LATINO
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS HAS CHOSEN
SB TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN. AS A
PRIORITY BILL DURING THE
WILDFIRES THAT DEVASTATED
CALIFORNIA OVER THE PAST THREE
YEARS DOMESTIC WORKERS AND
OTHER HOUSEHOLD WORKERS LIKE
DAY LABORERS HAVE BEEN ASKED TO
STAY BEHIND TO FIGHT FIRES
GUARD HOMES OR PETS WORK IN
SMOKY CONDITIONS AND CLEAN UP
TOXIC ASH ALL WITHOUT.
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT. AS FIRES
ONCE AGAIN RAVAGER STATE WE CAN
ONLY IMAGINE WHAT THIS
WORKFORCE IS ONCE AGAIN FACING
WITHOUT ANY HEALTH AND SAFETY
PROTECTIONS AND ON TOP OF. THE
ON GOING GLOBAL HEALTH PANDEMIC
IN ORDER TO PROTECT THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF DOMESTIC WORKERS
IN CALIFORNIA SB TWELVE FIFTY
SEVEN WOULD REMOVE THE
HISTORICAL EXCLUSION OF
PRIVATELY PAID DOMESTIC WORKERS
FROM CALIFORNIA'S OSHA.
STANDARDS THIS EXCLUSION IS
PART OF A LONG HISTORY OF
EXCLUDING DOMESTIC WORKERS FROM
BASIC PROTECTIONS AND AS PART.
OF THE ONGOING LEGACY OF
SLAVERY. RECENT AMENDMENTS ALSO
CLARIFIED THAT ANY
INVESTIGATION OF A VIOLATION OF
THESE PROTECTIONS MUST BE
CONDUCTED IN A MANNER THAT
AVOIDS AN UNWARRANTED INVASION
OF PERSONAL PRIVACY. THE
MEASURE HAS NO ORGANIZATIONAL
OPPOSITION AND RECEIVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE
POLICY AND FISCAL COMMITTEES OF
THIS HOUSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER VAST SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE- ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THIRTY VOTE. HOME MEMBERS VOTED
TO THEIR TO VOTE. ON MEMBERS
THIRTY THIRD OF A. WELL CLOSE
THE ROLE AND TALLY THOSE EYES
FORTY FOUR NEWS EIGHT THIS
MEASURE PASSES. WE WILL PASS
AND RETAIN ON FILE ITEM. WHAT
ONE OH NINE MOVING TO FILE ITEM
ONE TEN SB THIRTEEN NO ONE THE
CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN A ONE BY SENATOR HUESO
AN ACCOLADE OF PUBLIC RESOURCES.
MISTER WHERE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
ON THIS MATTER. THANK YOU
MEADOW SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
TO PRESENT SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
OH ONE BY SENATOR HUESO. AS
MANY OF YOU KNOW. THE ISSUE OF
CROSS BORDER POLLUTION IN THE
TIJUANA RIVER VALLEY HAS BEEN A
PROBLEM PLAGUING OUR OUTHERN
BORDER OF CALIFORNIA FOR MORE
THAN THIRTY YEARS. THIS
LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN DILIGENT
ATTEMPTED TO ADDRESS THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE. MULTIPLE
PIECES OF LEGISLATION ALONG
WITH MULTIPLE FUNDING. ITEMS
INTO VARIOUS STATE BUDGETS HAVE
BROUGHT US TO THE POINT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT RECENTLY
ALLOCATED THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE CLEAN UP. OF
OUR RIVER VALLEYS MARC U. S.
MEXCAN BORDER. ALL OF THESE
DEVELOPMENTS THE FUNDING THESE
LEGISLATION AND GET REQUIRE A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
REVITALIZING THE TIJUANA RIVER
VALLEY. AND THAT'S WHY WE NEED
WATERSHED WATERSHED ACTION PLAN
AS ENVISIONED IN THIS BILL-
THAT IS UPDATED EVERY THREE
YEARS TO PROVIDE RECOMMENDATION
ON SHORT TERM AND LONG TERM.
METHOD STRATEGIES AND PROJECTS
NOT JUST TO REDUCE THE
TRANSNATIONAL. FLOWS BUT HE
WANTED RIVER VALLEY BUT TO
IMPROVE BY NATIONAL COOPERATION
TO TACKLE THIS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ISSUE. WE NEED A CONSISTENT
LONG TERM PLANNING
COMMUNICATION ON BOTH SIDES OF
OUR BORDER- SO THAT PROGRESS IS
NOT LOST ANY TIME THERE ARE
CHANGES IN OFFICE. THE THREAT
TO PUBLIC HEALTH THAT IS THIS
ENVIRONMENTAL CATASTROPHE KNOWS
NO BORDERS. I ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS TODAY. THANK YOU MISS
GLORIA. SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS DESERVE A- ALL MEMBERS
THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. ON
MEMBERS VOTED A THIRD OF THOSE.
THE CLERK WILL WHO CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TELEVOTE IS FORTY
EIGHT NEWS HERE THAT MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS WE ARE PREPARED
TO LIFT THE CALL ON FILE ITEM
EIGHTY THREE SB FIVE FIVE FIVE
THE PURPLE POST. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED EITHER TO VOTE. HOME
MEMBERS GO TO THEIR TO THE.
OKAY ALL MEMBERS VOTED VERY
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO
THEIR TO VOTE. THE REQUIRES.
FORTY ONE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. EARLIER.
MISTER
CAR MOVE THE CALL. IN A FILE
ITEM ONE ELEVEN SB THIRTEEN
TWENTY THE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN TWENTY BY
SENATOR STERN ANOTHER SNACK
LEYVA CLIMATE CHANGE. MISTER
REVERSE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
MADAM CHAIR- MADAM SPEAKER
THANK YOU- COLLEAGUES THE
CONTINUED AFFECTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE ARE GLARINGLY APPARENT
OUR STATE IS CURRENTLY. ON FIRE
WE HAVE WILD FIRES OF
STAGGERING SCALE AND SPREAD
MOST OF WHICH WERE CAUSED BY
DRY LIGHTNING STORMS. WHICH
APPARENTLY CURB EVERY FIFTEEN
YEARS. JUST LAST WEEK
CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCED RECORD
BREAKING EXTREME HEAT THAT
STRAINED AND DEMONSTRATED THE
BONE ABILITIES OF OUR ELECTRIC
GRID. WHETHER IT'S WORSENING
WILDFIRES A PANDEMIC EXTREME
HEAT DROUGHTS OR ATMOSPHERIC
RIVER EVENTS. ARE STATUS
STARING DOWN A CLIMATE CRISIS A
CRISIS THAT WOULD DOOR LONGER
THAN ANYTHING WE HAVE CURRENTLY
EXPERIENCED. AND BY NOW IT'S
CLEAR OUR CHANGING CLIMATE IS
POSING ENVIRONMENTAL RISK AT A
RAPID PACE. BUT WHAT'S. NOT
CLEAR IS THE POTENTIAL ACAN EFE
OF ARE CHANGING CLIMATE. AND
THIS BEGS THE QUESTION HOW DOES
OUR CLIMATE CRISIS PLAYED OUT
IN ECONOMIC TERMS.
UNFORTUNATELY. ALL THE VALUABLE
CLIMATE RSEARCH THAT IS
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. IT DOES NOT REQUIRE
A SYSTEMATIC REVIEW OF OUR
CLIMATE LIABILITIES. THE
SUBSEQUENT ECONOMIC RISKS OF
THE CLIMATE CRISIS TO OUR STATE.
SUCH INFORMATION THESE ANALYSES
THAT ARE NOT ONLY POSSIBLE BUT
CRITICAL SO THAT WE CAN
PINPOINT PRECISELY WHERE WE ARE
MOST VULNERABLE AND THEN ACT
AGGRESSIVELY TO REDUCE RISK
THIS LEGISLATION SENATE BILL.
pTHE OFFICE SUPPLY IN A RESEARCH
TO COMPLETE A CLIMATE CHANGE
ASSESSMENT EVERY FIVE YEARS
THIS ASSESSMENT INCLUDES
PERIODIC RESEARCH REPORTS ON
TOPICS OF STATEWIDE IMPORTANCE.
THE ASSESSMENT REPORT WILL
EVALUATE HOW CLIMATE CHANGE
WILL AFFECT BUILT SYSTEMS
NATURAL SYSTEMS AND SOCIAL
SYSTEMS INCLUDING THE WELFARE
OF VULNERABLE. AREAS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE POTENTIAL
FISCAL AND ECONOMIC IMPACTS OF
THESE AFFECTS TO OUR STATE. THE
OFFICE OF PLANNING RESEARCH
WOULD ALSO REQUIRE. THE
ENGAGEMENT WITH REGIONAL AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WITH TRIBES
VULNERABLE AREAS IN OUR STATE
BUSINESSES AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC AS NECESSARY IN
DETERMINING THE SCOPE OF THE
ASSESSMENT. CLIMATE CHANGE
ASSESSMENT WILL PROVIDE UPDATES
ON THE COST IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE. TO BETTER ASSIST STATE
POLICYMAKERS WITH HOW WE CAN
RESPOND THERE'S NO KNOWN
OPPOSITION. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER THANK YOU MYSTERY
OF US SEEING HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THE MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ON THIS
MOVIE THIRD OF THE- ALL MEMBERS
OF THOSE WHO DESERVE IT. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. BURKE WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTE IS FORTY NINE
NEWS SIX THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING TO FILE ITEM. ONE
TWELVE. SB THIRTEEN FORTY ONE
THE CLERK WILL READ SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN FORTY ONE BY CENTRE
TODD- AND ACTUALLY BECOME WORKS
MISTRESS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
MELISSA BATTLE. SB THIRTEEN
FORTY ONE RELATED TO FAMILY
REUNIFICATION FOR CAL WORKS
FAMILIES. SB THIRTEEN FORTY ONE
WILL ALLOW CAL WORKS FAMILIES
WHOSE CHILDREN HAVE BEEN PLACED
INTO FOSTER CARE TO CONTINUE
RECEIVING MONTHLY CASH
ASSISTANCE WHILE ACTIVE
REUNIFICATION EFFORTS ARE
ONGOING WITHIN THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM. THE CURRENT
PRACTICE OF REMOVING CASH
ASSISTANCE FROM A FAMILY THAT
IS ALREADY BEFORE THE PUMP
BELOW THE POVERTY LINE MAKES IT
MORE DIFFICULT FOR FAMILIES TO
REUNIFY WITH THEIR CHILDREN.
ADDITIONALLY IT CAN DESTABILIZE
THE FAMILY AND ULTIMATELY
RESULT IN THE FAMILY BECOMING
HOMELESS. SB THIRTEEN FORTY ONE
WILL ENHANCE THE ABILITY OF
CHILD WELFARE PROGRAMS TO
REUNIFY FOSTER CHILDREN WITH
THEIR PARENTS BY ALLOWING
FOSTER BY ALLOWING CAL WORKS
FAMILIES WHOSE CHILDREN HAVE
BEEN PLACED INTO FOSTER CARE TO
CONTINUE RECEIVING. MONTHLY
CASH ASSISTANCE WHILE ACTIVE
REUNIFICATION EFFORTS ARE
ONGOING IN THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM ISN'T OUR CHILDREN'S
BEST INTEREST I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISS REST SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS NOTED THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
THEY'RE ALL MEMBERS VOTED VERY.
TO WHERE WILL LOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE EYES FIFTY NINE SIX
NO ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE PREPARED TO LET
THE CALL AND FILE ITEM EIGHTY
THREE SB FIVE FIVE FIVE THE
CLERK WILL PUT. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. HOME
MEMBERS WHO DESERTED THE- CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THE VOTE HIGHS FORTY FOUR KNOWS
FIVE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE PREPARED TO LET
THE CALL ON FILE ITEM FIFTY SIX
SB NINE SEVENTY TWO THE CLERK
WILL POST. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
EITHER TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS GO
TO DESERVE IT. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED DESERVE BOTH. FIRST FORTY
ONE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. IT'S A GREAT ROOM OF THE
CALL. MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
TAKE UP. ADDITIONAL BILLS FOR
PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS MOVING
TO FILE ITEM CHIU SB NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
WE WILL START
WITH FILE. ITEM TO SB NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ. SENATE BILL
NUMBER THE MINUTE BY BYE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CAREER. THIS
CARILLO ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
PURPOSE AMENDMENT THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THESE
ARE SIMPLY TRAPPED DURING OUT
AMENDMENTS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
MISS CAREER WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS ALL IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. I'LL JOSE NO. THE
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED OUT TO
PRINT AND BACK TO FILE. MOVING
TO FILE ITEM. ONE THIRTEEN SB
THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT THE CLERK
WILL READ SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
FORTY EIGHT WITH A MINUTES BY
SOME WOMEN FRIEDMAN. MISS
FRIEDMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
PURPOSES AMENDMENTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU THESE AMENDMENTS ARE
CHAPARRAL AMENDMENTS I REQUEST
AND I WILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISS FRIEDMAN WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS. ALL IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. I'LL SAY NO. THE AYES
HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS ADOPTED
OUT TO PRINT AND BACK TO FILE.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE SIXTEEN
SB. FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR. THE
CLERK WILL READ SENATE- FORTY
SEVENTY FOUR WITH A MAMMOTH
SPICE MEMBER LOW. MR LEVEL YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR PURPOSES
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF AN INSECURE AND MEMBERS THIS
IS A CAN BE BILL WITH
RETROSPECTIVE MENACE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MR LOW WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED SAY NO. THE AYES
HAVE IT THE AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED OUT TO PRINT THEM BACK
TO FILE. WE WILL PASS AND
RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS ONE
FOURTEEN AND ONE FIFTEEN THE
DISPENSED OF FILE ITEM ONE
SIXTEEN WE WILL PASS AND RETAIN
ON FILE ITEMS ONE SEVENTEEN
THROUGH ONE TWENTY ONE. AND
MEMBERS. ON BEHALF OF THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS I
WANT TO SAY A FEW WORDS ABOUT
THIS HISTORIC DAY TODAY IS THE
CENTENNIAL ANNIVERSARY OF THE
NINETEENTH AMENDMENT WHICH
GRANTED WOMEN THE RIGHT TO VOTE
NATIONALLY THIS WAS NOT AN EASY
BATTLE AND IT WAS A BATTLE THAT
CONTINUED FOR DECADES UNTIL WE
AS WOMEN GUARANTEED THAT ALL
WOMEN ESPECIALLY WOMEN OF COLOR
WE FIND OURSELVES READ ABOUT.
WOMEN HAVE COME SO FAR SINCE
NINETEEN TWENTY BUT WE HAVE
MUCH MORE TO ACCOMPLISH AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO BEING A PART OF
THAT CHANGE AS WELL AS SEEING
WHAT OUR FUTURE WOMEN LEADERS
DO PART OF THAT CHANGE WILL
COME BY GREATER NUMBERS OF
WOMEN EXERCISING THAT RIGHT TO
VOTE AND HOPEFULLY DECIDING TO
JOIN US AND RUN FOR PUBLIC
OFFICE. AND LET US REFLECT WE
HAVE ALWAYS. REMAIN AND WILL
CONTINUE TO PROTECT WOMEN'S
RIGHTS LET US CELEBRATE TODAY
AND AS WE MARK THIS HISTORIC
MOMENT I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
FOR BEING OUR PARTNERS IN THAT
FIGHT. IN THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
THE PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL LET THE CALL.
THE MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOORS
WINDOW TO ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. YEAH. OH SORRY MEMBERS
WE CAN ALL OF THE CALL WE HAVE
A BILL ON CALL. YES WE ARE
PREPARED TO LIVE THAT CALL FILE
ITEM FIFTY SIX SB NINE SEVENTY
TWO THE CLERK WILL POST. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE.
HOME MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE. WHERE WILL WHO. ALL
MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE IN TELLING VOTE EYES
FORTY ONE NO SIXTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES. NOW MEMBERS WE
CAN LIFT THE CALL AND MOVED TO
THE PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED A
JUDGMENT IN MEMORY. MEMBERS ARE
ALREADY.
LIKE. MEMBERS THE CALL
IS LIFTED.
THANK YOU MEMBERS
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS ARE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON IN GERMANY MEMORY
MISTER CHANG YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER TODAY I RISE. TO
IN GERMANY IN THE MEMORY OF MY
FRIEND THE CONSTITUENT JAMES
FAY. WHO SADLY PASSED ON FRIDAY
AUGUST FOURTEENTH AT THE AGE OF
FIFTY EIGHT. JAMES IS FROM A
TRAILBLAZING ASIAN AMERICAN
FAMILY IN OUR COMMUNITY. HIS
FATHER JOHN AND MOTHER FLORENCE
IMMIGRATED FROM TAIWAN IN THE
NINETEEN SIXTIES. THEY STARTED
A PUBLISHING EMPIRE FOUNDING
THE FORMER PUBLICATION ASIAN
WEEK IN NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE.
IN FROM THEIR PURCHASE THE
FORMER SAN FRANCISCO
INDEPENDENT. AND THEN THE SAN
FRANCISCO EXAMINER. THEY WERE
THE FIRST ASIAN AMERICAN FAMILY
TO OWN SB PUBLISHERS OF A MAJOR
DAILY NEWSPAPER THE STATES.
JAMES HIMSELF SERVED AS
PRESIDENT AND PUBLISHER OF
ASIAN WE FROM NINETEEN NINETY
FIVE UNTIL TWENTY TEN. END OF
THE EXAMINER FROM 200-022-0004
IN ITS OWN RIGHT JAMES IS A
TRAILBLAZER. HE WAS THE FIRST
ASIAN AMERICAN TO EVER WIN A
BAY AREA WHITE POST ACCORDING
TO THE CHRONICLE WHEN HE WAS
ELECTED TO THE BART BOARD. IN
NINETEEN NINETY SERVING SIX
TERMS UNTIL TWENTY FOURTEEN.
DURING HIS TENURE BARRED
IMPROVE THIS TECHNOLOGY AN
EARTHQUAKE PREPAREDNESS. HE
OVERSAW RENOVATION AND
EXPANSION PROJECTS TOTALLY
TWELVE BILLION DOLLARS. IN HIS
LEADERSHIP HAS LEFT OUR REGION
IN THAT INSTITUTION
SIGNIFICANTLY BETTER. JAMES WAS
ALSO THE CHAIR OF OUR SAN
FRANCISCO SHANGHAI SISTER CITY
COMMITTEE I THE HONOR OF GOING
WITH HIM TO SHANGHAI ON
NUMEROUS OCCASIONS IN HIS
LEADERSHIP AND FRIENDSHIP HELP
BRING THE TWO CITIES IN OUR TWO
COUNTRIES. SIGNIFICANTLY CLOSER.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS MOTHER
FLORENCE FRANK OF HILLSBOROUGH
WIFE DAPHNE UPON THE SAN
FRANCISCO BROTHER TED FENG OF
HILLSBOROUGH NEPHEW SEAN FRANK
OF SAN MATTEO NIECE ALLISON
FAILING OF SAN MATTEO. HE WAS A
GOOD FRIEND WE WILL MISS HIM
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP AND HIS
COMMUNITY ACTIVISM. AND WE
ASKED TODAY THAT ARE ASSEMBLY
ADJOURNED IN HIS MEMORY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MR CHANG MR CHU
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
ADJOURNMENTS THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I WOULD LIKE TO JOIN MY
WEBSITE SAN FRANCISCO
COLLEAGUES. IN A DURING TODAY'S
MEETING IN THE MEMORY OF JAMES
FINE. OUR COLLEAGUE HAS LAID
OUT HIS. ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND
THE POSITIONS HE HELD WHICH ARE
ALL TREMENDOUS BUT I WANT TO
JUST SHARE. HE AND HIS FAMILY.
HELP TO MOVE OUR CHINESE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY FOR IN SO
MANY WAYS. THROUGH THEIR
LEADERSHIP AND JOURNALISM THEY
TOLD OUR STORIES AND HELP TO
UPLIFT THE TRIALS THE
TRIBULATIONS THE TRIUMPHS AND
STRUGGLES OF OUR ASIAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES. AS SOMEONE WHO WAS
ONE OF OUR EARLIEST CHINESE
AMERICAN ELECTED ¿ICIALS
HELP LAYS THE WAY FOR SO MANY.
TO COME BEHIND HIM. AND AS
SOMEONE WHO CONTRIBUTED SO MUCH
TO OUR CITY WHEN IT COMES TO
INFRASTRUCTURE. WHEN IT COMES
TO THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN SAN
FRANCISCO AND THE BAY AREA AND
SHANGHAI IN CHINA. WHEN IT
COMES TO BRING COMMUNITY
TOGETHER THIS IS WHAT JAMES
FINE. EXEMPLIFIED AND I WANTED
TO SEND A PERSONAL WE WILL
REMEMBER. HIS SERVICE BUT WE
ALSO REMEMBER HIS JOVIAL NATURE
WE REMEMBER HIS SMILE IS EASE
AND EVERYTHING IS DONE AND I
WOULD LIKE TO JOIN OUR
COLLEAGUE AND WISHING HIS
INCREDIBLE FAMILY. TO HIS
MOTHER FLORENCE HIS BROTHER TED
TO HIS WIFE DAPHNE AND ADDRESS
THE FRANK FAMILY OUR DEEPEST
CONDOLENCES AND ASSET WE
ADJOURNED IN HIS MEMORY. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MISTER CHU YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE NEXT TO
GERMAN IS MEMORY AS WELL. MIKE
ABOUT SPEAKER. TODAY'S WITH
SADNESS THAT I ASKED WE ARE
TURNING THE MEMORY OF JEAN
MORRISON A LIFELONG PROGRESSIVE.
ORGANIZER IN SAN FRANCISCO WHO
PASSED AWAY AT THE AGE OF ONE
HUNDRED LAST MONTH. REFERRED TO
BY SENATOR BARBARA BOXER AS THE
GRUNBAUM OF SAN FRANCISCO
POLITICS. JANE DEVOTED NEARLY A
HALF CENTURY TO LOCAL STATE AND
FEDERAL CAUSES. HE BECAME
INVOLVED IN POLITICS WHEN HER
HUSBAND. FIRST RAN FOR THE SAN
FRANCISCO BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
AND SHE WAS A PUBLIC AFFAIRS
DIRECTOR AT A LOCAL RADIO
STATION. SHE BECAME THE WOMAN'S
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY. DURING
PRESIDENT KENNEDY'S
PRESIDENTIAL RACE. THE ONE TIME
RADIO EXECUTIVE WENT ON TO HOST
EVENTS FOR MERGING CANDIDATES
INCLUDING. OUR BODIES FORMER
SPEAKER WILLIE BROWN SENATOR
BARBARA BOXER AND SPEAKER NANCY
PELOSI. SHE WAS A PUBLIC FIGURE
HERSELF SERVING ON A MYRIAD OF
ADVISORY COMMITTEES EAD
RELATED TO SOCIAL JUSTICE AND
THE ENVIRONMENT. INCLUDING A
DECADE HONOR HUMAN SERVICES
COMMISSION AND WINNING SEATS
THROUGH MULTIPLE ALEXION'S OUR
DEMOCRATIC COUNTY CENTRAL
COMMITTEE. MOST IMPORTANTLY.
JAMES STOOD OUT NOT JUST
BECAUSE THE BECAUSE SHE TOOK
UP. BUT BECAUSE OF HER ABILITY
TO MAKE FRIENDS AND NOT CREATE
DIVISIONS. AND A POLITICAL
COMMUNITY THAT'S OFTEN RIFE
WITH THEM. AS SPEAKER PELOSI
RECENTLY REMARKED. THE QUALITY
FOR ALL THAT'S WHAT JIM
MORRISON HAS BEEN ABOUT WE'VE
ALL LEARNED SO MUCH FROM HER
ORGANIZING SPIRIT DEVOTION TO
PROGRESSIVE CAUSES AND TALENT
FOR BRINGING PEOPLE TOGETHER
AND BODIES THE PROGRESSIVE
VISION THAT IS THE CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO PAUL EXACERBATE JOIN
ME IN EXTENDING OUR DEEPEST
SYMPATHIES. TO HER FAMILY
FRIENDS LOVED ONES AND OUR CITY
IN A TIME OF DEEP UNCERTAINTY-IN CIVIL UNREST IT'S IMPORTANT
WE HONOR THE PIONEERS OF OUR
STATE WHO FOUGHT THE EARLY
FIGHT FOR QUALITY WITH THAT AS
A WE RESPECTFULLY TURN IN THE
MEMORY OF JIM MORRISON. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MISTER KING
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE
GERMAN OF MEMORY. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MONITORED JOIN MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN FRANCISCO
IN. ASKING THIS ASSEMBLY TO
JOURNAL THE MEMORY OF JIM
MORRISON. YOU WERE NOT
INITIATED INTO SAN FRANCISCO
POLITICS TO YOU WENT TO ONE OF
HER HOUSE PARTY. ONE OF HER
MANY EVENTS. AS MY COLLEAGUES
HAVE MENTIONED HER HISTORY IN
OUR COMMUNITY. REPRESENTS A
WHO'S WHO OF SAN FRANCISCO
POLITICS. YOU WANT SOMEONE WHO
AT REALLY ARRIVED INTELLIGENT
MORRISON DECIDED TO HOST YOU AT
HER HOUSE FOR ONE OF OUR MANY
HOUSE PARTIES AND THAT. STARTS
WITH WHETHER IT'S PEOPLE PELO
SEE. WITH A WAS A FORMER SENATE
PRO TEM JOHN BURTON WHETHER THE
SENATOR BOXER. IN THE LIST GOES
ON AND ON. ONE OF MY FAVORITE
MEMORIES OF A TIME AT JAMES
HOUSE WAS SHE WOULD ALWAYS
HOST. AN ANNUAL NEW YEAR'S
CHINESE OF LUNAR NEW YEAR'S.
FUNDRAISER FOR ONE OF OUR
PROMINENT CHINESE AND ORGAN.
INSTEAD FRANCISCO. TWO ONE
CELEBRATE. GIVE BUT ALSO TO
BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER. AND
THAT'S REALLY WHAT CHEN
EXCELLED SHE EXCELLED AT
BRINGING. A VARIETY OF PEOPLE
IN OUR COMMUNITY GATHER. TO
REMIND US THAT THEY'RE ISSUES
THAT WE CARE ABOUT THAT WE
NEEDED TO WORK CALL. IN THAT IT
WAS IMPORTANT TO WORK ON FOR
GRASSROOTS LEVEL. SHE WAS THE
CONSUMMATE GRASSROOTS ORGANIZER
LONG BEFORE IT BECAME POPULAR
ON THE INTERNET SHE WAS ALWAYS
THERE TO. STUFF ENVELOPES MAKE
PHONE CALLS MAKE SURE THAT THE
WORD GOT OUT ON A VARIETY OF
ISSUES I WILL HAVE SO MANY.
FOND MEMORIES AND IF YOU GO
BACK AND READ WHETHER YOU GO
BACK AND READ- YOU KNOW WILLIE
BROWN BIOGRAPHY OR- FILL BIRDS
BIOGRAPHY YOU'RE GOING TO SEE.
HER NAME HER FAMILY'S NAME IN
ALL THE VARIOUS ISSUES THAT SHE
FOUGHT FOR OVER OUR CITY'S
HISTORY. OUR CITY IS THE BETTER
HAS A BETTER FOR HER
PARTICIPATION. AND WE WILL
SORELY MISS HER I ASKED THAT WE
HAD DURING THE MEMORY OF JIM
MORRISON THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
CHANG MR CHEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE NEXT TO
GERMAN MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER FOR YOUR TIME. I RISE
TODAY TO TURN THE MEMORY OF
GREG JENKINS. GREG JENKINS THE
FATHER A MENTOR THAT DEAR
FRIEND OF MY DISTRICT PROFESSOR
JODI BALMA. REJECT WAS BORN IN
EVERETT WASHINGTON IN NINETEEN
THIRTY NINE. HE SPENT MOST OF
HIS YOUNG LIFE IN ARIZONA AND
SERVE THE ARMY BEFORE MOVING TO
CALIFORNIA TO ATTEND THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
pGRADUATING FROM USC CREDIT
JACQUI MOVED TO TURLOCK. THE
BUILD A THRIVING BUSINESS FOR
NEARLY FORTY YEARS UNTIL HIS
RETIREMENT IN TWO THOUSAND.
PROJECT AND BELIEVES STRONGLY
IN COMMUNITY SERVICE AND
LEADERSHIP. HE SERVED ON THE
BOARD OF THE SALVATION ARMY OF
PROLONGING WITH A MEMBER OF THE
AMERICAN CALIFORNIANS STANISLAW
DENTAL SOCIETY. EVEN THE FORMER
PRESIDENT AND MEMBER OF THE
COLLECTION CLUB AMONG MANY
OTHER MEMBERSHIPS. I GOT TO
LEARN FROM MR GREG JENKINS WHEN
HE WAS ELECTED TO DRUG JOINT
UNIT SCHOOL DISTRICT OVER BOTH
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS IN A
RESPECTIVE SCHOOL BOARDS. HE
WAS KNOWN FOR ITS EXTREME
GENEROSITY AND HOSPITALITY. ALL
WELCOME INGINKAN FAMILY HOME.
PROJECTED NEVER LOST HIS LOVE
LEARNING. AND SHARE MANY
INTERESTS WITH THOSE THAT
INCLUDE A LOT OF HISTORY.
ALTERYX FINANCIAL INVESTMENTS
MOVIES AND SPORTS. WE HAD AN
AMAZING ATTITUDE AND MENTOR ALL
THOSE AROUND HIM. A SPORTSMAN
IN EVERY SENSE OF THE WORD GREG
JENKINS WERE PLAYING GAMES AND
SPORTS AND LOVE WATCHING ALL
THREE CHILDREN AND LATER HIS
GRANDCHILDREN SPORTING'S EVENTS
ACTIVITIES. ON AUGUST THIRD
KRIGING CAN PASSED AWAY
INTERLOCK ALONGSIDE HIS FAMILY
HOLDINGS WIFE'S HAND AFTER
CELEBRATING THEIR FIFTY SEVENTH
WEDDING ANNIVERSARY JUST A FEW
DAYS EARLIER ON. PROJECTION
WE'VE GOT A FAMILY COOL
TREASURE THEIR MEMORIES OF A
LIFE WELL LIVED AND ALL OF ITS
ADVENTURES. HE IS SURVIVED BY
HIS WIFE PEGY JANGAN TWO SONS
KEITH AND BARRY JENKINS AND HIS
DAUGHTER. PROFESSOR JODI BALMA.
ALONG WITH THEIR FAMILIES AND
MANY GRAND AND GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN. THE PROJECT IS
NO LONGER WITH US PHYSICALLY
HIS TEACHINGS AND THOSE ARE THE
SHE- VALUES WILL MOVE ON ALL
THOSE THAT YOU TOUCH. WHAT WE
DO IN LIFE ECHOES IN ETERNITY.
AT HOME WE ASK THE ASSEMBLY
DRAWN IN THE MEMORY MISTER GREG
JENKINS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN. MR MEDINA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF DR SAUDARA TELAH. SAU WAS A
GREAT EDUCATIONAL LEADER
INNOVATOR AND MENTOR. AS A
LEADER OF THE RIVERSIDE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT HIS
TENURE BEGAN AS PRESIDENT
SUPERINTENDENT OF A SINGLE
ACCREDITED COLLEGE IN THE MIDST
OF AN ECONOMIC DOWNTURN. SAU
OVERSAW THE EXPANSION OF THE
DISTRICT INTO A SYSTEM OF THREE
SEPARATELY ACCREDITED COLLEGES
WHILE FACING SEVERE FISCAL
CONSTRAINTS. SAU REFUSED ANY
PAY RAISES THAT WOULD EXCEED
THOSE OF HIS EMPLOYEES AS
CHANCELLOR INCLUDED AS PART OF
HIS CONTRACTUAL OBLIGATIONS
TEACHING ONE CLASS PER YEAR. AS
HE WANTED TO DEMONSTRATED TO
FACULTY AND STUDENTS ALIKE THE
CENTRALITY OF TEACHING. AS THE
INSTITUTIONAL MISSION. HE
HEALED DIVIDED FACULTY AND
CURRENT ENCOURAGE THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES TO TAKE A PRINCIPLED
STAND IN FAVOR OF INCLUSION AND
DIVERSITY. FOUR YEARS INTO HIS
TENURE CELTIC THE CHALLENGE OF
RAISING THE COLLEGE GRADUATION
RATE IN OUR COMMUNITY WHICH WAS
AMONG THE LOWEST IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. HIGHLIGHTING A
FEW OF THE MANY ACCOMPLISHMENTS
ACCOMPLISHMENTS ATTRIBUTED TO
SELL LEADERSHIP SPEAKS OF HIS
COMPETENCE BUT HARDLY DOES
JUSTICE TO THE QUALITIES AS A
HUMAN BEING. IS SO SURVIVED BY
HIS WIFE BALAD THREE SONS AND
GRANDCHILDREN. ASKED THAT WE
ADJOURNED THE MEMORY THE STOCK
OR SELL RETTELLE. THANK YOU MR
MEDINA MISTER BLOOM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY. BAKER MEMBERS TO I RISE
TO ADJOURN THE MEMORY OF CARL
REINER ONE OF OUR- MOST GIFTED
COMEDIC WRITERS WHO DIRECTED
AND ACTED IN MANY ICONICFILMS
AND TELEVISION SHOWS. THAT MADE
MILLIONS LAUGH AND REFLECT ON
THE HUMAN CONDITION. THE
BELOVED CREATOR OF THE DICK VAN
**** SHOW WAS BORN IN THE BRONX
ON MARCH TWENTIETH NINETEEN
TWENTY TWO. AT SIXTEEN HE BEGAN
TAKING FREE ACTING CLASSES THAT
ARE BEING OFFERED BY THE WORKS
PROJECT IN PROGRESS
ADMINISTRATION DRAMATIC
WORKSHOP. AN ACTING AT A
THEATER IN MANHATTAN. REINER'S
FIRST PAID ACTING GIG ONLY
ARGUMENT DOLLAR WEAK BUT WHEN
WORLD WAR TWO BROKE OUT HE
BEGAN TOURING THE SOUTH PACIFIC
AS PART OF THE SPECIAL SERVICES
ENTERTAINMENT UNION UNIT
PERFORMING IN G. I REFUSE.
AFTER BEING DISCHARGED IN
NINETEEN FORTY SIX REINER
PERFORMED IN A NUMBER OF
BROADWAY SHOWS. BUT DIDN'T GET
ISRAEL BREAKING ACTING UNTIL HE
JOINED THE CAST OF NBC'S YOUR
SHOW OF SHOWS FEATURING SID
CAESAR AND IMOGENE COCA. IN
NINETEEN SIXTY REINER WROTE AND
STARRED IN A PILOT CALLED HEAD
OF THE FAMILY ABOUT A COMEDY
WRITER WHO LIVED IN NEW
ROCHELLENEW YORK. THE SHOW WAS
A REFLECTION OF REINER'S OWN
LIFE AT THAT TIME UNFORTUNATELY
THAT PILOT WASN'T A SUCCESS.
BUT HE REWORKED. THE SHOW FROM
THE NEW ACTOR TO TAKE THE LEAD
ROLE. AND A YEAR LATER CAME OUT
WITH THE DICK VAN **** SHOW ONE
OF THE MOST CELEBRATED AMERICAN
SITCOMS OF ALL TIME. AND WIDELY
CONSIDERED A PIONEERING EGGS OF
THE GENRE. REINERT REGARDED
DICK VAN SOW HIS GREATEST
ACCOMPLISH AND WITH GOOD
REASON. THE SERIES FOLLOWED
ROBIN LAURIE PETRI FOR FIVE
SEASONS SPENDING A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY EIGHT APSOS. AND THE SHOW
REPEAT RECEIVED NUMEROUS AWARDS.
BUT HE ALSO DIRECTED AND ACTED
IN A NUMBER OF MEMORABLE FILMS
INCLUDING THE COMIC THE JERK.
DEAD MEN DON'T WEAR PLAID AND
OH GOD RECENTLY HE APPEARED IN
THE OCEAN'S ELEVEN SERIES OF
FILMS PLAYING SAUL BLOOM NO
RELATION. REINER WAS ALSO A
PROUD DEMOCRAT WHO FREQUENTLY
TOOK TO TWITTER WITH WITTY
REMARKS AND COMMENTARY ON
CURRENT EVENTS AND OUR
POLITICAL DISCOURSE THROUGH HIS
WRITING ACTING AND DIRECTING.
CARL REINER CONSISTENTLY
RECOGNIZED OUR COLLECTIVE NEED
TO LAUGH AND EXPERIENCE JOY. HE
PUT IT QUITE SIMPLY ONCE SAYING
EVERYBODY WANTS TO LAUGH YOU.
KNOW THAT THEY NEED TO LAUGH
PEOPLE NEED TO LAUGH. IN THAT
TRUE. DURING THESE TRYING TIMES
WE CERTAINLY DO NEED LAUGHTER
AND LEVITY WHEREVER WE CAN FIND
IT. CARL REINER PASSED AWAY ON
JUNE TWENTY NINTH AT THE AGE OF
NINETY EIGHT THE LAUGHTER. FOR
A LIVES WILL TRULY BE MISSED.
MR REINER SURVIVED BY HIS SONS
ROB AND LUCAS HIS DAUGHTER ANNE
AND FIVE GRANDCHILDREN AND
ASKED WE ADJOURNED IN THE
MEMORY OF CARL REINER. THANK
YOU MISTER BLOOM. MR DON'T.
KNOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN MEMORY. YOU THANK
YOU I MAY SPEAKER. I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF JERRY
MENDOCINO. HE IS THE FATHER OF
RAMEN AGAIN WHO WORKS IN THE
SPEAKER'S OFFICE DOWN IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND THE
HUSBAND. BORN IN SAN PEDRO
JERRY WORK AT THE FAMILY'S FISH
MARKET BEFORE MOVING ALONG TO
THE LONG BEACH NEIGHBORHOOD OF
BIXBY KNOLLS WITH HIS WIFE
SUSAN. ONCE THERE HE BECAME A
RESPECTED COMMUNITY LEADER BY
HELPING FORM THE BIXBY
HIGHLANDS NEIGHBORHOOD
ASSOCIATION. AND SERVING THREE
TERMS ON A LONG BEACH AIRPORT
ADVISORY COMMISSION WHERE HE
WAS RATHER VOCAL. JERRY ALSO
INSPIRED COUNTLESS USED TO MAKE
A DIFFERENCE. GET INVOLVED AND
GIVE BACK TO THE COMMUNITIES BY
WORKING WITH THE BOY SCOUTS OF
AMERICA FOR OVER TWENTY FIVE
YEARS. EVEN SERVING AS THE
SCOUTMASTER OF A SON BRIAN'S
TRUE AND LONG BEACH BRIAN WAS
VERY INVOLVED IN THE SCOUTS
BECAUSE HIS FATHER. JERRY
ENJOYED SPENDING TIME WITH HIS
FRIENDS ATTENDING DANCING. AT
NATIVE AMERICAN POWERS AND WAS
AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA INDIAN HOBBYIST
ASSOCIATION. N. THE CALIFORNIA
HAS GOT. IT EVERY MEMORIAL DAY
FOR THE PAST TWENTY YEARS YOU
COULD FIND JERRY PUTTING FLAGS
ON THE GRAVES OF VETERANS AND
LOCAL CEMETERIES. JERRY WILL
DEEPLY BE MISSED BY HIS WIFE
SUSAN. AGAIN A RETIRED TEACHER
HIS TWO SONS GERALD AUTHORED
AND BRIAN. FIVE GRANDCHILDREN
AND TWO GREAT GRANDCHILDREN HIS
SISTERS JOANN JERILYN AND KATHY
AS WELL AS ALL HIS FRIENDS IN
THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF BIXBY
KNOLLS. THE COMMUNITY OF ST
PETER AND THE CITY OF LONG
BEACH HE WAS VERY ACTIVE AND A
GREAT VOICE FOR THE
NEIGHBORHOOD. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF GERMANY JERRY
MENEGHINI MINISTRY KERR. THANK
YOU MISTER THOMAS RODRIGUEZ YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
IN MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS A ROSTER DURING
THE MEMORY OF EIGHTY SECOND
AIRBORNE DIVISION PARATROOPER
ENRICA ROMAN MARTINEZ WHO LIVE
WITH THIS FAMILY AND MY
DISTRICT IN THE CITY OF CHINO.
ENTIRE COMMUNITIES AGREEMENT
AFTER THE LOSS OF THIS YOUNG
CARING MAN WHO WAS KILLED OVER
MEMORIAL DAY. ON WHAT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE A FUN CAMPING
TRIP TO NORTH CAROLINA'S OUTER
BANKS HIS FAMILY IS NOW
DEVASTATED. THIS PAST SATURDAY
AND BECAUSE REMAINS WERE LAID
TO REST AS RECEIVED MILITARY
HONORS. WE'RE ALL REMIND OF HOW
BELOVED HE WAS WAS FAMILY AND
FRIENDS. HE IS REMEMBERED AS A
LOVING BROTHER KAREN SON AND
LOYAL FRIEND. IN THIS FOR YEARS
THE U. S. ARMY SERVICE IN
RINKER BECAME A PARATROOPER AND
A HUMAN RESOURCE SPECIALIST.
AND RICK IS ALSO SERVED AS A
MEMBER OF THE IMMEDIATE
RESPONSE FORCE MEANING HE COULD
BE DEPLOYED ANYWHERE IN THE
WORLD AT ANY TIME. AND WE CAN
HAVE BEEN RECOGNIZED WITH
COMMENDATION SUCH AS THE ARMY
COMMENDATION MEDAL THE GLOBAL
WAR ON TERRORISM SERVICE MEDAL.
THE ARMY SERVICE RIBBON AND THE
BASIC PER TO PER BAG BATCH. AND
RICKETS SERVICES NATION
HONORABLY AND HE DESERVES OUR
RECOGNITION FOR HIS SACRIFICE
AND SERVICE. HE IS ALSO A HERO
WILL BE DEEPLY MISSED BY MANY.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN HONORING ARMY
SPECIALIST IN THE CARE ROMAN
MARTINEZ AND THE MEN AND WOMEN
OF THE UNITED STATES ARMY BY
JOINING IN HIS MEMORY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MYSTERY GUEST
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
THE DESK BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL ALL REQUEST TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS THE
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS.
THURSDAY AUGUST TWENTY SEVEN
WHO HAVE FOR SESSION AT NINE AM
AND FRIDAY AUGUST TWENTY EIGHTH
FLOOR SESSION WILL BE UPON CALL
OF THE SPEAKER.ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED
ENTERTAINED. ALMOST ENSURE WE
CONTINUE TO SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER BUSINESS I'M READY
TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN. MR BONTA MOVES IN THIS
CARILLO SECONDS THAT THE HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL.
THURSDAY AUGUST TWENTY SEVENTH
AT NINE AM.